GOOD AFTERNOON- I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY. I'M BILL CHURCH COURT
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS
PAD- JUST HERE THERE IS A MASK
REQUIRE FOR IN TO IN THE ROOM
PLUS- PLEASE MAINTAIN PROPER
MASK USAGE AT ALL TIMES DO NOT
REMOVE OR LOWER YOUR MASK WHEN
SPEAKING. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY FOR UP
TO TWO MINUTES AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. IN ADDITION TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WILL HAVE THE
OPTION OF TESTIFYING IN REMOTE.
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM AT THE END
OF THE HEARING IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM WHAT YOU'RE DONE.
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE. TO A SMALL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AT THE TIME. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN SO GET ON THE CALL
IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO.
ZERO TWO. SO AGAIN THE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MOOD MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART
DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY. YOU
CAN CALL- THE OFFICE- MY OFFICE
AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
916-319-2020 AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY AND HELP. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITNESS AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
AND KEEP THEM SAFE- TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO DISCUSS THE CHALLENGES
OF SCALING UP SEASONAL ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGY. IN ORDER TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE ZERO
CARBON. AND WE'RE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED HERE ABOUT. NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND HOW WE WOULD
BRING THE MEN TO- A
COMMERCIALIZATION. ADDRESS B.
ONE HUNDRED WE IN THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE. SAID
AMBITIOUS GOAL OF MAKING
ELECTRICAL GRID ZERO CARBON BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THERE
CERTAINLY EFFORTS TO EVEN DO IT
FASTER THAN THAT. HOWEVER AS WE
USE MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY. AND
THEY COME ON LINE. RENEVIA
SOLUTIONS PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
WITH OF COURSE A RELIABLE
ENERGY SUPPLY. DESPITE SEASONAL
VARIATIONS IN SOLAR AND WIND
POWER PRODUCTION AND OTHER
METHODS IT WILL PROBABLY BE
DEVELOPING OVER TIME. RIGHT NOW
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA
IS LIKELY TO BE OVER GENERATED
IN THE SPRING AND SUMMER MONTHS
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. AND
IT IS NOT LIKELY TO MEET OUR
DEMANDS IN THE WINTER- FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE GONNA NEEDS.
STORAGE NOT ON THE ORDER OF. IT
TOOK ABOUT LONG TERM STORAGE IS
SOMETHING MORE THAN FOUR HOURS.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE THAN FOUR DAYS
PROBABLY ON THE ORDER FOR
MONTHS OR EVEN LONGER. AND
pABOUT THIS. SEASONAL ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES CAN FILL
THE GAP BY PROVIDING ENERGY
ENERGY STORAGE. SO THAT WELL WE
HAVE A SURPLUS IT'S SOMETIMES
OF YOURS AND THE WINTER WHEN
WE'RE LIKELY TO HAVE A DEFICIT
WE CAN AGAIN HAVE A RELIABLE
SUPPLY. HOWEVER MANY SEASONAL
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
CURRENTLY IN RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT STAGE ARE NOT
COMMERCIALLY DEVELOPED
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DISCUSSING TODAY. THESE
TECHNOLOGIES- MAKE IT. A NEED
TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE
CHALLENGING PHASE OF
COMMERCIALIZATION. KNOWN AS THE
VALLEY OF DEATH. SO YOU CAN
HAVE A SOFTWARE COMPANY A START
UP LIKE FACEBOOK. AND IT STARTS
BY SERVING THE PEOPLE AT
HARVARD AND THEN THE IVY LEAGUE
AND THEN COLLEGES AND THEN. THE
REST OF THE US AND THEN THE
WORLD YOU COULD SCALE IT UP.
SCALING UP ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES
VERY DIFFERENT YOU CAN HAVE A
LAB PROCESS YOU'RE GONNA NEED A
PILOT PLANT THE PILOT PLANT
THAT IS GOING TO REQUIRE REALLY
pREALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR
ECONOMY IS GOING TO BE INTO
YOUR BILL THESE ON THIS
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO ENSURING THAT SEASONAL
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES ARE AT
SCALE AND COST EFFECTIVE IN
TIME. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A
ZERO CARBON BRIDGES BOTH THE
TECHNICAL CHALLENGE IN THE
POLICY PROP CHALLENGE WHAT WE
CAN DO IS POLICY- TO ENCOURAGE
THESE COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENTS
WITHOUT. IN OUR FINGER ON THE
SCALE AND SAYING THI IS THE
ONE BECAUSE FRANKLY. YEAH IT
SHOULDN'T BE CHOSEN BY. I
LEGISLATORS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO. LOOK AT EXPERTS
MARKET CONDITIONS IT CETERA. SO
THE PURPOSE OF THE HEARING
TODAY IS TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE
OF SEASONAL STORAGE WILL BE
FIRST ASKING HOW MUCH ARE WE
LIKELY TO NEED. THE CHALLENGES
COMMERCIALIZATION OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THEN WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO ENSURE. THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
ENERGY STORAGE IN A TIME TO
MEET OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE OR
PERHAPS EVEN EARLIER GOALS. AND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING THE TECHNOLOGY IS
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
ANYTHING FASTER IS AN EMERGENCY
WHICH WERE IN. SO I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE WITNESSES WILL BE
WITH US TODAY PLEASE NOTE THAT
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SHARE
THEIR VIEWS AT THE END OF
HEARING. NOW I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS AND
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES- WITH NOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHANNEL. THANK YOU FOR-
SO THE FIRST. PART THAT WILL
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT HERE.
THE FIRST PANEL I HAD TO START
OFF TODAY- GABE MURTADA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR. WILL TALK TO
US ABOUT THE NEED TO THE GREAT
IN THE ROLE OF SEASONAL ENERGY
STORAGE AS MORE RENEWABLE.
ENERGY SOURCES ARE BROUGHT
ONLINE. SO I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD
OTHER QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END
OF THE PANEL. WHEN WE CAN
DIRECT- QUESTIONS TO BOTH
SPEAKERS. ARM AND THE NEXT-
SPEAKER AFTER- MISTER MURTADA-
WILL BE DOCTORS SERRA COURAGE
FROM UC MERCED AND WE'LL GET
INTO THAT A LITTLE LATER SO- MR
MURTAJA CAN YOU COME ONLINE AND
SPEAK TO US. AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. WHAT BOB WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY BEN KIRK- DR
KURT AND THE VERY DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE SECOND PANEL OF
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY AND
OTHERS WHO ARE LISTENING IN
IT'S A GREAT PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AND SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY.
HI MY NAME IS DAVE BURKE LAW
AND MY OFFICIAL TITLE HALF
CALIFORNIA ISO IS STORAGE
SECTOR MANAGER AND- IF THAT. I
MEANS WHAT IT SAYS I MANAGE
MOST THINGS THAT THE ISO RELATE
TO STORAGE. LIKE NEW POLICIES-
THAT ARE COMING ONLINE NEXT
MODELS THE RESOURCES AT OUR
MARKET AND EVENTUALLY GET THEM
COMPENSATED FOR THE ENERGY THAT
RESTORED RESOURCES THAT THEY
MOVE AND POORLY FROM ONE PART
OF THE DAY TO THE OTHER. AND
FOR- OPTICAL RESEARCH
DEPARTMENT FOR THE ENERGY TO
GET- SO WITH THAT IN MIND I'M
GOING TO BE SPEAKING ON A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE JUST MENTIONED AND
SETTING THE BACKDROP BACKDROP
FOR THE CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DAY. SO FOR
REFERENCE AND IT IS NUMBERS
THAT WE CAN KEEP IN MIND THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM IS A SUMMER
PEAKING SYSTEM. AND IT TAKES
THAT JUST UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. DOWN DURING THE
SUMMER DURING THE MOST CRITICAL
HOURS OF NEED FOR THE SYSTEM.
CONDITIONALLY MOST OF THE LOAD
IN THE STATE HAS BEEN SERVED
WITH NATURAL GAS FIRED
GENERATION AND OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE SEEN DEEPER AND DEEPER
PENETRATION OF RENEWABLE
RESOURCES. AND YOUR ACCOUNT
YEAH THAT'S TRUE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY YOUR CALIFORNIA'S
RENEWABLE RESOURCES HAVE
PRIMARILY BEEN SOLAR ALTHOUGH
WE DO HAVE SOME WIND GENERATION
AND FROM SMALL HYDRO FACILITIES
ON OUR SYSTEM AS WELL THAT MAKE
UP SOME OF THAT GENERATION- THE
STORAGE RESOURCES IN PARTICULAR
HAVE BEEN GROWING. CONSIDERABLY
RETURNS- YEARS AND MONTHS- JUST
FOR REFERENCE LAST YEAR WE HAD
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MAKE A LOT
OF WORDS ON OUR SYSTEM. TODAY
WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF STORAGE OR SYSTEM
SO AGAIN FOR A TOTAL SYSTEM
THAT SERVING A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN FIFTY THOUSAND MEGAWATTS-
A JUMP OF ONE THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF ANY TECHNOLOGY IS
A PRETTY RADICAL CHANGE. AND A
JUMP OF A THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
NEW GENERATION OF SOMETHING
THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
ONLINE. PRIOR TO THAT IS A VERY
BIG CHANGE- THAT APPLY
ADDITIONAL WORLD. THAT THE
SYSTEM OPERATOR NEEDS DID YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE RESOURCES
WORK- HOW TO USE THESE
RESOURCES THE MOST EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY AND- HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO INTEGRATE WITH
THE REST OF THE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE ONLINE I JUST WANT I HATE
TO INTERRUPT GONE GONNA BREAK
MY OWN RULE. UP THAT'S FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF POWER HOW
MANY HOURS CAN. YOU RUN THAT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATT.
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THREE
HOURS SO NEARLY AND I WAS JUST
ABOUT TO GET TO THAT- BUT
NEARLY ALL OF THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE IN OUR SYSTEM TODAY
OUR LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. AND
MOST OF THE RESOURCES ON OUR
SYSTEM OUR FOUR HOUR DURATION
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF YOU
HAVE A PLUS OR MINUS TEN
MEGAWATT BATTERY SO IT CAN
EITHER CHARGE FOR AS MUCH AS I
CAN MAKE A LOT WORKING JUST
CHARGE AS MUCH AS TEN O'CLOCK
ANY INSTANTANEOUS POINT IN
TIME. THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF STATE
CHARGES THOSE RESOURCES CAN
ACCOMMODATE IS BETWEEN ZERO
MEGAWATT HOURS AND FORTY
MEGAWATT HOURS SO THEY CAN.
TAKE. OUR DURATION SOME OF THEM
ARE ONLY ONE HOUR DURATION AND
THAT'S WHAT BRING THE AVERAGE
DOWN JUST A LITTLE BIT. VERY
GOOD PLEASE PROCEED. ABSOLUTELY
SO THE NOTED THE CHANGES AND
THE CAPACITY VALUES- YEAR OVER
YEAR ARE VERY VERY LARGE- THE
LAST TIME THAT WE'VE SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS WITH ABOUT
TEN YEARS AGO WHEN WE HAD
SIMILAR YOU KNOW I WOULD I
WOULD CALL EXPLOSIVE GROWTH OF
SOLAR ACROSS THE STATE AND
DURING THAT PERIOD WE HAD
INCREASES OF ABOUT ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR PER
YEAR AND FRANKLY WE'RE
OF INCREASES OF THIS FOUR HOUR
DURATION- BUT YOUR MIND STORAGE
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS- SO. I
WANTED TO STAGE A LITTLE BIT
AND PERHAPS THE QUESTION OF WHY
ARE WE HERE TODAY WELL WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
SEASONAL ENERGY STORAGE. AND
THE FIRST THING THAT I WOULD
KNOW IS THAT THE DATE. THE
LITTLE STORAGE IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT NECESSARILY DEFINED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ISO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S NECESSARILY
DEFINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES CMMISSION-
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ON OUR GREAT TODAY
AND NOT SOMETHING THAT WERE
OPERATING. SO I THINK- THE
FRAMEWORK THAT ASSEMBLY MAKE
WORK SET UP AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS CALL IS EXACTLY CORRECT.
WE'RE VERY MUCH IN THE
EXPERIMENTAL AND THEORETICAL
PHASES OF. WHAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
COULD POTENTIALLY DO IN THE
FUTURE AND WE'RE NOT YET AT A
POINT WHERE. WE'RE REALLY
CONSIDERING- IT WERE LOOKING
ACTUAL OPERATIONAL DATA FOR
THESE RESOURCES- SO WE SHOULD
KEEP THIS IN MIND- THAT RIGHT
NOW IT'S PRIMARILY AN ACADEMIC
EXERCISE. BUT AS WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS EVEN
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF BUT
YEAH MY ON BATTERIES AT SHORTER
DURATION LEVINE BATTERIES- THAT
WE CAN GO VERY QUICKLY FROM
ACADEMIC EXERCISES. TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING THESE RESOURCES ON
THE GRANT. EXISTENTIALLY USING
THEM TO RETIRE TRADITIONAL
RESOURCES- THAT ARE EITHER OLD
WORK POTENTIALLY- MORE
POLLUTING THAN OTHERS. SO WHY
IS ENERGY NECESSARY I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE CRITICAL
QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES. AND ENGINEERS
WORKING THIS QUESTION IS YOU
KNOW RIGHT AT THE DOORSTEP SB
ONE HUNDRED WHERE WE HAVE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET A 100%
GREENHOUSE GAS. FREE
ELECTRICITY GENERATION BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT- THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IN
CALIFORNIA I ALSO ARE THINKING
ABOUT VERY HARD- AND HAD AND
TRYING TO. NAVIGATE OUR WAY.
TOWARD HALF THAT WE CAN GET TO
A SOLUTION- TO HAVE G. H. G.
FREE ELECTRICITY GENERATION. SO
IN THE NEAR TERM WHAT THAT
MEANS IS RETIRED YET IT COULD
DISCERN THIS ON THIS PROCESS IN
THE NEAR TERM WHAT THAT MEANS
IS RETIREMENT- VERY OLD AND
EXPENSIVE AND NOT PARTICULARLY
EFFICIENT AFTER GAS GENERATING
RESOURCES AND REPLACING THOSE
RESOURCES IN AN IDEAL WORLD-
WITH SOME SORT OF A TECHNOLOGY
THAT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FREE. OKAY CALIFORNIA TODAY I
HAVE NEVER MENTION THIS
AFFECTED WE MEAN- REPLACING IT
WITH WIND OR SOLAR GENERATION
OF SOME VARIETY. UNFORTUNATELY
AND I'M REALLY HOPING THAT THIS
ISN'T NEWS TO ANYBODY- WE
ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF SOLAR
RESOURCES ON OUR SYSTEM TODAY
AND ADDITIONAL GENERATION FROM
SOLAR- COULD POTENTIALLY. PUT
THE SYSTEM IN A POSITION WHERE
WE HAVE SATURATION DURING SOME
HOURS OR EVEN SOME OF THE YEAR-
TODAY YOU GOING INTO SPRING IS
ALREADY NOTED IN THE
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS WE DO
HAVE A FREQUENT NEED THAT
BACKGROUND SOLAR GENERATION FOR
PEAK OUTPUT AND THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING- BECAUSE WE ARE
GENERATING MORE SOLAR ENERGY
THAN IS NEEDED. TO SERVE HELLO
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
THIS OCCURS FOR THREE. REASONS
THERE'S OTHER. THAT THAT PLAY A
ROLE AS WELL. BUT IN THE SPRING
WE DO TYPICALLY. HI SOLAR HIGH
ENOUGH STORAGE IN GENERAL- SO
WE HAVE MORE SUPPLY. WE ALSO
HAVE SPRINGTIME RUNOFF SO THE
ICE AND SNOW IS MELTING OF THE
MOUNTAINS THAT INCREASING THE
GENERATION THAT WE GET FROM OUR
RUN OF RIVER HYDRO RESOURCES
WHICH IS ALSO INCREASING THE
SUPPLY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE FINAL IN THE SPRING WE
ALSO TYPICALLY HAVE COOLER
WEATHER WHICH TRANSLATES TO LOW
OR MODERATE LOWS. ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. AND THIS MEANS THAT-
YEAH ONE FACT. THAT CALL. IT
JUST OVER GENERATIONS OF
ELECTRICITY- SO RIGHT NOW-
DURING THOSE SUMMER TIME
PERIODS WHEN WE HAVE OUR
ABSOLUTE HIGHEST HE NEED FOR
THE SEASON- WE HAVE JUST ENOUGH
AGGREGATE GENERATION TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS YEAH THERE ARE
EVENING HOURS- NEED NEED
TYPICALLY OCCUR AFTER THE SUN
GOES DOWN. SO EFFECTIVELY IF WE
BROUGHT ON HUNDRED TONS AND
TONS OF NEW SOLAR IT WOULD
REALLY HELP US MEET THE NEEDS-
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED THE
ENERGY AFTER THE SOLAR IS
ALREADY OFFLINE FOR THE DAY- SO
WHAT CAN POTENTIALLY DO
OBVIOUSLY THE ANSWER IS- YEAH
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE. SHORT
DURATION BATTERY SO IF WE DO
INTEGRATE MEANS- LITHIUM ION
FOUR HOUR DURATION BATTERIES
LIKE WE'RE DOING ON OUR SYSTEM
TODAY WE CAN SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
WE CAN BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY WHEN WE
GOT SOLAR ONLINE AND IN THE END
OF THE DAY AFTER SORTS OFFLINE
WILL BE HAVE A GREATER NEED FOR
GENERATION. AND THEN MORE STILL
AFFECTED WE GETTING HI THERE
ARE- VERY LOW COSTS ARE VERY
EFFICIENT GAS GENERATION OR
POTENTIALLY ON THOSE DAYS AND
WE HAVE SOLAR CURTAILMENT-
WE'RE GETTING ACCESS SOLAR
INTEGRATED WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GENERATE AND
STORE- STORED IN ELECTRONIC
BATTERIES AND THEN THEY CAN BE
USED AND DISPATCH. UNDERGRAD AT
A LATER POINT IN THE DAY. SO
RIGHT NOW FOUR INVESTMENT IN ME-
THE NEED IS AT THE OF THE DAY
AND AT- JUST JUST FOR TARGETED.
BUT AS WE GET DEEPER AND DEEPER
STORAGE PENETRATION ON THE
GRAND EVENTUALLY WE'RE GONNA
NEED STORAGE THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR MORE THAN JUST A
FEW HOURS OF THE DAY- AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE OFFERING TO
OR IS TYPICALLY REFERRED TO AN
INDUSTRY AS- LONGER RATIONS
STORAGE SO WE'RE EVENTUALLY
GOING TO NEED BATTERIES THAT
ARE CAPABLE OF. PROVIDING EIGHT
HOURS A STORAGE DURATION OR TEN
HOURS OF STORAGE DURATION OR
EVEN MORE- AGAIN AS WE GET MORE
RETIREMENT OF TRADITIONAL
RESOURCES AND START REPLACING
THEM WITH RENEWABLE RESOURCES
WIND OR SOLAR- AND TO BE HAPPY
BATTERIES TO COLLECT EXCESS
WIND OR SOLAR- FROM THAT
GENERATION AND THEN. MOVED TO
ACTIVELY MOVE THAT INTERVIEW
FROM ONE TIME OF THE DAY TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE DAY- IF WE
YOU KNOW- I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT.
AS WE GO FURTHER IN THE FUTURE-
WE'RE IN WE'RE GOING TO START
THE FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES ARE
GRANTED THE BIGGEST AT NEED ARE
GOING TO SHIFT FROM- THAT THOSE
SUMMER VERY HIGH HEAT DAYS TO
ACTUALLY- THE WINTER WHEN WE
HAVE POTENTIALLY LOWER SOLAR
GENERATION YET AGAIN AL GORE
RICH. MAKEUP CHANGES WILL HAVE-
PLENTY OF OTHER SOLAR
GENERATION IN THE SUMMER WHEN
THE SUN IS ABUNDANT BUT IN THE
WINTER WHEN DAYS ARE MUCH
SHORTER AND SO WE'RE
GENERATIONS LAST WILL START TO
FEEL THE PINCH- IN THE
OVERNIGHT HOURS WHEN THERE'S NO
SOLAR GENERATION- AND IT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE EXACERBATED BY
FEAR IS WHEN THERE'S VERY
LITTLE WIND DURING THE DURING
OUR CROSS ENTIRE DAY AND THAT'S
REALLY THE TIME FRAME WHEN WE
START TO SEE A SHIFT FROM THE
NEED. FOR STORAGE RATIO AND
THAT IS PERHAPS ONLY A FEW
HOURS- TWO ONE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY STAND- FOR MOVING
ENERGY DURING THESE RELATIVELY
ABUNDANT TIMES PERHAPS IN THE
SUMMER- FOR THE FALL. YEAH IN
THE WINTER. WHEN THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF SO WE'RE GONNA
WHICH STATE WILL BE RELY ON. AS
WE SEE OUR RENEWAL GENERATION
SOLAR GENERATION INCREASE OVER
THE YEARS- SO IF WE WERE LIKE
IN THE TO A MARATHON RACE. I
WOULD SAY- AMERICAN RACING THE
RACE WAS- WHERE WE ARE IT'S
EARNS OUT THINKING ABOUT AND
MOVING TOWARDS DIFFERENT
STORAGE SOLUTIONS WELL
BASICALLY JUST GETTING OFF THE
STARTING BLOCK- WE'RE LEARNING
HOW BATTERIES OPERATOR GRANT WE
STARTED TO DESIGN MODEL THAT
CAN ACCOMMODATE STORAGE
RESOURCES ON OUR GREAT. AND AS
THOSE MODELS. YEAH YOU KNOW
WHAT FORMING OF MODEL AND THERE
THEY WILL IMPROVE AND OF ALL TO
ACCOMMODATE THE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF FUNCTIONS THAT BATTERIES CAN
PERFORM- BUT THAT DOES TAKE
TIME AND- EFFORT. AND
EVENTUALLY WILL START YOU NEED
THESE OTHER KINDS OF STORAGE
RESOURCES AS WELL MIDWAY
THROUGH THE RACE WILL BE
THINKING ABOUT- LONGER DURATION
STORAGE IN THAT EVENTUALLY
TOWARD THE END OF THE RACE.
WELL WHO WILL START YOU NEED TO
THINK ABOUT- SEASONAL STORAGE
AND HOW THAT PLAYS INTO MARKETS
BUT WE'RE VERY VERY LONG WAY
OFF FROM DOING THAT AT THIS
POINT- IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT
OF EXTRA STUDY AND A LOT OF
EXTRA RESEARCH. YOU KNOW HOW
THESE ARE GOING TO HATE AND TO
SET UP THE RIGHT INCENTIVES. TO
GET THE PROPER RESOURCES
ONLINE- AND THEN THE RIGHT
MARKET TOOLS IN PLACE. THAT WE
CAN USE THESE RESOURCES
PROPERLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO GET
ELECTRICITY. THIS CALIFORNIA.
I'M SHE ARTS ABOUT MINUTES TEN-
SO PROUD AWHILE FOR OF ALL I'M
JUST COULD TO TRY AND ADD A
COUPLE OF POINTS TO AUDIENCE
MAY NOT FOR BEING FAMILIAR WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY YOU CAN'T REALLY
USE BATTERIES TO STORE POWER
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS YOU GET SELF DISCHARGE
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH LITHIUM
AND COBALT AND OTHER MATERIALS
TO MAKE BATTERIES WHICH CAN
STORE THING FOR MONTHS IT'S
JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT IS.
LIKELY TO HAPPEN. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
THERE ARE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
WHICH WILL GET INTO WHICH-
BATTERY ORIENTED SUCH AS- FLOW
BATTERIES AT CETERA BUT- THE
CURRENT TECHNOLOGY IS NOT ONE
THAT'S GOING TO STORE THING FOR
MONTHS. THE OTHER THING IS IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A WINTER
DAY WHERE THERE'S AND- YOU'VE
DONE A GREAT JOB WITH THE ISO
SHOWING THE WINTER DAYS WITH NO
SIGN AND NO WIND. THAT THIS
HAPPENS YOU'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT MANY GIGAWATTS. OF WET
SUMMER DEMAND IS ACHIEVING
WINNER DEMAND IS PROBABLY
THIRTY GIGAWATT THIRTY
GIGAWATTS- THIRTY THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PERHAPS- SOMETHING LIKE-
GEOTHERMAL WHICH IS BASELOAD
PERHAPS SOME OTHER BASELOAD
TECHNOLOGIES WERE DEVELOPED BUT
WE'RE TALKING ON THE ORDER OF
TENS OF GIGAWATTS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
GENERATION NEEDED. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT FOR PERIODS OF
DAYS. MAYBE WEEKS- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE MOST EXTREME CASE AND WE
KNOW WE CAN'T AFFORD TO BE
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY FOR EVEN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME FOR HEALTH
SAFETY AND ECONOMIC REASONS. SO
WE REALLY ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE OF. GIGAWATTS OF CAPACITY
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
CAPACITY ON THE ORDER OF CHANCE
TEN TO TWENTY SOMEWHERE IN
THERE PROBABLY. AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT STORAGE FOR AT
LEAST WEEKS. AS OPPOSED TO
HOURS MAYBE FOR MONTHS. IT'S
JUST AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
DIFFERENT AND I JUST GO- I
THINK THAT- AS AN EXPERT- YOU
WERE IMPLYING THIS BUT I JUST
WANTED TO GET THAT POINT ACROSS
TO THE AUDIENCE- I'D NOW LIKE
TO OPEN THIS FOR QUESTIONS-
MISTER CHANNEL. ANYONE NOW-
WELL. QUESTION BUT I THINK UP
PLEASE DO THINK I'D LIKE TO
HEAR THE OTHER SPEAKERS FIRST
BEFORE I GET INTO THE QUESTION
OKAY MAKE SURE GOING TO COVER-
SO I THINK WE'VE GOTTEN. TO
THAT POINT- I REALLY. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A- THE NEXT SPEAKER
COMES FROM THE BEST KEPT SECRET
IT YOU SEE UC MERCED. AND IF I
WERE GOING TO TALK TO A STUDENT.
AND THEY SAID WE REALLY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO MAKE OUR GRID
WORK. I'D SAY GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MERCED.
AND TALK WITH DR SARAH KURTZ.
SHE HAS AN AMAZING RESUME I'M
GONNA TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
OFF FROM THE USUAL PROPOSAL
JUST READ SOME OF THIS. PHD
FROM HARVARD THIRTY YEARS SAID
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
LABORATORY IN GOLDEN COLORADO.
KNOWN FOR HER COLLABORATIONS
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO DEVELOPING
MULTI JUNCTION SOLAR CELLS AND
MORE RECENTLY WORK ON
PHOTOVOLTAIC PERFORMANCE
RELIABILITY. WORK HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED WITH THE JOINTLY
RECEIVED DAN DAVID PRIZE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. THE CHERRY
AWARD IN TWENTY TWELVE AND THE
C. THREE E. LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND INDUCTION TO THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF ENGINEERS
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND- NATIONAL
ACADEMY IS IT OF ENGINEERING
ONLY HAS THE BEST ENGINEERS IN
THE WORLD. AS PART OF THAT
ACADEMY. SHE'S NOW AT- UC
MERCED WHERE SHE STUDIED THE
VALUE OF LONG DURATION STORAGE
UNDER CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION GRANT. AND I KNOW
SHE'S VERY EXCITED TO- TO SPEAK
TO US TODAY AND TO SUPPORT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADOPTION
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY THROUGH
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION. SAID DR
CURTIS- WE-WERE VERY ANXIOUS
TO HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE TO BE
ABLE TO COME AND JOIN YOU TODAY
AND IT'S A SPECIAL TREAT
BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH AN
EXCITING TIME FOR- THE INDUSTRY
WITH THE TRANSITION INTO A NEW
ENERGY SYSTEM CAN YOU CONFIRM
THAT YOU CAN BOTH HEAR ME AND
SEE MY SLIDE OKAY. YES OKAY SO
I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT SEASONAL ENERGY STORAGE
WHICH IS A NECESSITY FOR AS LOW
CARBON GRID. BUT I'D LIKE TO
START BY POINTING OUT THAT
ENERGY STORAGE IS A NECESSITY
FOR ANY ANY ENERGY SYSTEM. AND
EFFECTIVE DAY IF YOU LOOK THE
EIA MAINTAINS A DASHBOARD TO
TRACK THE NATURAL GAS STORAGE
CONCEDED DIFFERENT REGIONS OF
THE COUNTRY. HERE YOU CAN SEE
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR.
THE STORAGE IN THE UNDERGROUND-
IN NATURAL GAS STORAGE IT WILL
DECREASE DURING THE WINTER AS
IT'S USED FOR HEATING AND THEN
OVER THE SUMMER. THE REFILL
THAT CAVERN WITH MORE NATURAL
GAS THEY ALSO TRACK- OIL AND
OTHER THINGS AND HERE I HAVE. A
COLLECTION OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT YOU CAN SEE. WITH
THE- DIFFERENT TYPES OF STORAGE
RESERVOIRS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THIS IN TERMS OF IF YOU TOOK
THIS ENERGY IN THESE AND USED
IT TO POWER THE ELECTRICITY
GRID WE COULD POWER THE US
POWER GRID FOR ALMOST A HALF A
YEAR WITH THESE RESEARCH CENTER
THERE. SO INTERESTING QUESTION
IS WHO PAYS FOR THE STORAGE THE
CUSTOMERS WHO GET THAT NATURAL
GAS IF IT WAS STORED DURING THE
SUMMER AND THEN THAT STILL PER
TO THEM WITH WINTER HEAT
THEY'LL PAY A LITTLE BIT EXTRA
FOR THE WINTER. TIME NATURAL
GAS BECAUSE THE PRICES ARE
HIGHER IN THE WINTER- BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT SAY THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE AND IF YOU'VE
BEEN AROUND AS LONG AS I HAVE
YOU REMEMBER THE OPEC OIL
EMBARGO SOME YEARS AGO WHICH
MOTIVATED US TO CREATE THIS.
IT'S REALLY THERE FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY WHEN PEOPLE DO THE
MODELING TO SAY WHAT'S THE COST
OF STORAGE WE NEED TO MEET TO
BE ABLE TO PAY FOR THAT
STORAGE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LENGTH OF TIME THE ENERGY HAS
BEEN IN THAT STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE AND WHETHER
IT COULD MAKE A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT- YOU'LL FIND THAT
NOBODY CAN MAKE A BUSINESS
MODEL OUT OF THIS IT'S NOT A
BUSINESS MODEL FOR BEING ABLE
TO DO ENERGY SALES IT'S THERE
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY. SO I
SUGGEST THAT WHEN WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT ENERGY STORAGE
WE NEED TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN PRACTICALITY AND
SECURITY. AND I'M THEIR
DIFFERENT TECHNICAL TERMS YOU
MAY USE FOR THIS BUT JUST TO
NOTE PRACTICALITY IS THAT WE
NEED STORAGE FOR THE NIGHT TIME
AND FOR CLOUDY DAYS WE ALSO
NEED STORAGE THAT- I CALL
SEASONAL HERE AND THE
DIFFERENTIATING OF THESE- CAN
GET A LITTLE COMPLICATED BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS
THAT'S HERE FOR SEASONAL. IS
LARGELY FOR SECURITY. THE WE
WANT TO HAVE AN INSURANCE
POLICY AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SCRIPT AGAIN YOU CAN SEE THE
DURING THE WINTER IT COMES
DOWN. BUT THIS GRAY AREA IS
LOOKING AT A FIVE YEAR MINIMUM
AND MAXIMUM AND WHAT YOU SEE IS
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE
YEARS WE NEVER GO DOWN TO ZERO.
WE INTENTIONALLY SIZE THE
STORAGE SO THAT WE NEVER GO
DOWN TO ZERO BECAUSE E WANT
THE INSURANCE. THAT IF
SOMETHING REALLY STRANGE
HAPPENS AND HAVING JUST BEEN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WE CAN ALL
SEE THAT STRANGE THINGS CAN
HAPPEN. THINGS THAT WE NEVER
EXPECTED CAN DISRUPT THE SUPPLY
CHAINS. AND HERE WE BUILT THIS
IN TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR ENERGY BECAUSE ENERGY
IS SO FOUNDATIONAL FOR SOCIETY
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT THERE AS
SECURITY. SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SEASONAL- STORAGE I HOPE
WE CAN BE THINKING ABOUT NOT
JUST DELIVERING- THAT KILOWATT
HOUR ONCE A YEAR AFTER THAT
STORAGE IN NEEDING TO PAY FOR
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT PAYING
FOR THE SECURITY. SO KEY
QUESTION TO BE INTERESTING TO
DISCUSS IS WILL DECARBONIZE
ENERGY SYSTEM NEED MORE FOR
LESS STORAGE HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TWO DAY IN THE US WE
HAVE MAYBE SIX MONTHS WORTH. IN
THE FUTURE WE PROBABLY DON'T
NEED THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVE BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR OWN
SUNSHINE SO WE DON'T NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT AN OIL EMBARGO. BUT
WE DO NEED TO WORRY ABOUT A BIG
STORM AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN
THERE- I'D LIKE TO TALK NEXT
ABOUT FOUR OF THE REALLY
EXCITING APPROACHES TO SOLVING-
AT LEAST PARTS OF THESE
PROBLEMS. AND THERE ARE SO MANY
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE I COULD-
TALK ABOUT TODAY I'VE CHOSEN
THESE FOR- LARGELY BECAUSE I DO
SEE THAT THEY HAVE. A REAL
SCALABILITY- AND ALSO BECAUSE
MAYBE I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
BATTERIES TODAY BECAUSE YOU'VE
ALL HEARD ABOUT BATTERIES SO
I'VE- CHOSEN THINGS THAT MAYBE
GIVE YOU A LITTLE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAN WHAT YOU
TYPICALLY LOOK AT. SO THE FIRST
STRATEGY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS USING AS MAKING HYDROGEN. SO
WE SOMETIMES THINK ABOUT
BUILDING MORE SOLAR WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT THAT IF WE BUILD
MORE SIMILAR THAN WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE OVER GENERATION AND
THEN WHAT DO WE DO WITH THAT.
FIRST I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT. NECESSARILY
TURNING THE SOLAR PLANT OFF IS
A BIG DEAL. IT'S TRIVIAL TO
TURN A SOLAR PLANT OFF IT'S
HARDER TO TURN A NATURAL GAS
PLANT OFF THERE'S- WEAR AND
TEAR ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NATURAL GAS PLANT TURNING IT ON
AND OFF IN A COAL PLANT. OR
NUCLEAR PLANT CAN TAKE LIKE A
FULL DAY TO TURN THEM ON AND
OFF. I'M IN A PEAKER PLANT MADE
SIT IDLE MOST OF THE YEAR AND
ONLY GET TURNED ON ONCE IN
AWHILE. SO IF WE TURN OFF THE
SEWER PLANT 10% OF THE YEAR IT
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE TO THE SOLAR PLANT
ALTHOUGH IT DOES MEAN THERE'S
pLESS RETURN. TO THE INVESTOR ON
THAT. BUT LET'S SAY IF WE BUILD
MORE SOLAR. AND WE BUILD MORE
ELECTROLYTES HERS WHAT I'VE
DRAWN OVER HERE. IS THE MONTHLY
ELECTRICITY AS A FUNCTION OF
THE TIME OF YEAR AND HERE'S THE
MONTHLY GLOW THAT WAS OBSERVED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IF WE
SCALED UP THE SOLAR GENERATION
THAT WE SAW IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BIG ENOUGH THAT DURING
THE WINTER MONTHS YOU ACTUALLY
GENERATE ENOUGH ELECTRICITY. TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPLY THAT THE
WINTERTIME MODE. WE HAVE NOW
ALL THIS EXTRA AND YOU CAN VIEW
THIS IS A PROBLEM BUT YOU COULD
VIEW IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY WE
NEED HYDROGEN WE'RE GOING TO
NEED HYDROGEN TO DRIVE FUEL
CELLS TO MAKE FERTILIZER. WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO MAKE THAT
HYDROGEN AND SO IF WE LOOK AT
NOW WE'VE MADE ALL THESE
ELECTROLYTES HERS. WE CAN USE
THEM DURING THE TIME WHEN YOU
SEE THIS YELLOW WE CAN USE THAT
TO MAKE THE HYDROGEN AND THEN.
WHEN WE GET INTO THE WINTER WE
CAN JUST TURN THIS OFF IN FACT
THEY WANT TO TURN OFF. THE
ELECTROLYZER IS TO MAKE
HYDROGEN IT'S ECONOMICAL IF THE
PRICE OF ELECTRICITY IS LOW BUT
WHEN THE PRICE OF ELECTRICITY
GOES UP. IT BECOMES
UNECONOMICAL TO MAKE HYDROGEN
SO THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO
TURN OFF DURING THOSE TIMES. SO
THESE NEW ELECTRICAL LOADS
LIKE- AND ELECTROLYZER ENABLES
US TO USE MORE DEMAND
MANAGEMENT AND I NOTE THAT
AROUND THE WORLD THE AND- IN
HIGH. IS SO THESE ARE EXPENSIVE
TECHNOLOGIES NOW BUT AS THEY GO
FORWARD IT WILL BE LESS. IN
LOOKING NEXT AT- THE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE ARE
READY. TO BE SCALED UP. THE WE
CAN USE COMPRESSED AIR. THERE
ARE ALREADY TOO LARGE
COMPRESSED AIR STORAGE SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN OPERATING FOR
DECADES. I AM VERY INTRIGUED BY
HI RESTORE HAS MADE AN
INNOVATIVE ADVANCED VERSION OF
THE COMPRESSED AIR. WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IS INSTEAD OF
USING A SALT CAVERN THERE
AREN'T THAT MANY PLACES IN THE
WORLD WHERE THERE'S SALT
CAVERN- LOW IN THE GROUND
INSTEAD WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS
TO. GO DOWN AND HOLLOW OUT IN
AND THE NEED REALLY SOLID ROCK
SO KEEP IN MIND. THAT WHEN
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT DRILLING
DOWN AND MAYBE BRING IN OIL OUT
FRACKING OR WHATEVER YOU NEED
REALLY POROUS ROCK. SO YOU CAN
GET THE OIL TO COME OUT BUT IN
THIS CASE THEY NEED REALLY
SOLID ROCK BUT THEY GO DOWN AND
HOLLOW OUT THAT REALLY SOLID
ROCK. AND THEN THEY ALSO PUMP-
THE DRILL HOLE DOWN. AND PUT
WATER DOWN WITH A BLADDER HERE
WHICH ALLOWS THEM. TO OPERATE
THIS AT A CONSTANT PRESSURE
MODE WHICH ALLOWS THEM. TO DO A
DEEP DISCHARGE WHERE IS THE
HISTORICAL COMPRESSED AIR. IF
YOU RUN IT DOWN SO ALMOST ALL
THE ERRORS OUT OF IT IT DOESN'T
HAVEAS MUCH PRESSURE BUT WITH
THE BLADDER YOU CAN KEEP THE
PRESSURE HIGH. BETA PROJECTS
RUNNING AROUND THE WORLD TO
DEMONSTRATE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY. AND YOU CAN SEE
IT'S VERY SCALABLE IT'S BUILT
ON BEING ABLE TO DRILL WELLS
THE OIL INDUSTRY IS LOOKING FOR
WAYS. TO APPLY THEIR SKILLS TO
CLEAN ENERGY. AND A USES MINING
TECHNOLOGY SO IT'S USING THAT
SKILL SETS AND EQUIPMENT THAT'S
ALREADY READILY AVAILABLE AND
VERY SCALABLE- SIMILARLY IF YOU
TAKE COMPRESSED AIR INTAKE A
LITTLE FURTHER- YOU COOL IT
DOWN. IF YOU NO LONGER HAVE TO
COMPRESS IT SO MUCH- IF YOU
COULD ENOUGH TO BECOMES LIQUID
AND MANY OF YOU ARE MOST OF YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH LIQUID
NITROGEN. SO MAKING THERE IS
VERY SO- HI IF YOU POWER IT HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS TECHNOLOGY
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE. I'M
THEY STORE THE ENERGY IN THE
LIQUID AIR AND THEY HAVE
PROJECTS GOING. IN SPAIN AND
CHILE AT A UTILITY SCALE SIZE.
THIS IS A GREAT SCALABLE IT'S
USING. THE TANKS THAT STORE THE
CRYOGENIC LIQUIDS ARE
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME TANKS THAT
YOU USE A FOR LIQUEFIED NATURAL
GAS AND IF YOU'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING. THE NATURAL GAS
INDUSTRY YOU KNOW THAT THE HUGE
DEVELOPMENT IS THAT IN THE
GOLF. THEY'VE PUT IMPORTS THAT
CANS- LIQUEFIED NATURAL GAS PUT
IT ON SHIPS AND THEN SHIPPED
AROUND THE WORLD AND EXPORT
NATURAL GAS TO OTHER PLACES. SO
THIS IS TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
AVAILABLE ON A VERY LARGE
SCALE. AND AGAIN THE COMPANIES
WHO HAD BEEN INVESTING IN THE
FOSSIL FUELS ARE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO USE THEIR SKILLS. TO
HELP TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THIS. HI
HE WAS VERY INTERESTED IN
DOING- PROJECTS INC IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS SOME OF
THESE OTHER PLACES AROUND THE
WORLD. NOW THIS- LAST EXAMPLE
THAT I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU IS
ONE I WAS VERY SKEPTICAL WHEN I
FIRST HEARD OF IT. BUT THE MORE
I'VE LEARNED OF IT THE MORE
IMPRESSED I AM. WITH THE ENERGY
IS LOOKING AT STORING THE
ENERGY AND- BY COMPRESSING THE
ROCK. WHAT THEY DO IS TO DRILL
A HOLE DOWN DEEP. AND THEN THEY
<c.magenta>AKE A HORIZONTAL FRACTURE</c>
HERE. NOW AGAIN THEY NEED VERY
SOLID ROCK IF THIS IS POOREST
ROCK LIKE THE KIND OF ROCK THAT
YOU FIND IF THERE'S OIL AROUND.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DRILL DOWN
TO ADAPT THAT PUTS THEM INTO
POROUS ROCK THEY'RE GOING TO
DRILL TO A GAP THAT'S REALLY
SOLID ROCK AND THEY NEED. TO
SEE. THIS CAVERN. THE PUSH THE
WATER. AND WHEN THE WATER COMES
DOWN IT FORCES THE- THEY ON
ROCK ON THE TOP TO LIFT UP. AND
THE ROCK HUNDRED NEEDS TO PRESS
DOWN. AND THE ENERGY THAT
SPENDING THAT COMPRESSED ROCK
YOU'D THINK OF ROCK AS A SPRING
BUT EFFECTIVELY IT CAN WORK AS
A SPRING. IN THE CONSTRUED
STORE TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
ENERGY THERE. THE USE OF HYDRO
POWER OF MOVING WATER TO BE
ABLE TO TURN A TURBINE IS WELL
ESTABLISHED FOR HYDRO POWER
AROUND THE WORLD. THEY'VE GOT
PROJECTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
IN CANADA AND AGAIN THIS IS
VERY SCALABLE. THEY CAN BRING
IN A DRILL THEY TELL ME THAT
THEY CONTROL THIS WHOLE IN A
DATE USING STANDARD OIL. DRILL
SORTS OF TECHNOLOGY. AND THEN
THE HYDRO POWER EQUIPMENT IS
ALSO READILY AVAILABLE- IF
THESE PROJECTS- ARE SUCCESSFUL
IN DEMONSTRATING THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTROL OF THIS AGAIN WE CAN
USE THOSE- COMPANIES THAT ARE
OUT THERE ALREADY WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND KNOW HOW. TO
DEPLOY THIS ON A HUGE SCALE. SO
JUST IN SUMMARY- THE ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTIONS WHAT ROLE THE
STORAGE PLACE. STORAGE IS
NEEDED TO GET THROUGH THE
NIGHT- SEASONAL STORAGE IS
PRIMARILY AN INSURANCE POLICY
SO THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT. TYPES
OF. MARKET MECHANISMS WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW MUCH
STORAGE DO WE NEED- OUR
ESTIMATES ARE WE GOING TO NEED
ABOUT A QUARTER OF A TERAWATT
HOUR FOR DIURNAL STORAGE. THE
WORST CASE I FIND FOR SEASONAL
STORAGE COULD BE ABOUT 10% OF
THE ANNUAL LOAD. I DON'T THINK
THIS IS LIKELY I THINK THAT IF
WE BUILD MORE SOLAR SO THAT WE
CAN MEET THE NEED TO GENERATE.
HYDROGEN THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
AND IF WE DO IT SMARTLY IT GETS
COMPLICATED BUT I CAN TELL YOU.
I THINK WE CAN GET DOWN TO THE
AMOUNT OF SEASONAL STORAGE WE
NEED WOULD BE LESS THAN 1% OF
THE AND A LOAD- WHAT
TECHNOLOGIES. I DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT BATTERIES I DID TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHERS FOR
THE SEASONAL STORAGE WE'RE
LOOKING AT MORE THE CHEMICAL
STORAGE. AND WE ALSO NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE THESE TYPES OF THINGS LIKE
HYDROGEN THAT WILL BE USING FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND INDUSTRIAL.
SO WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE A
SEPARATE RESERVOIR THAT'S JUST
FOR THE POWER SECTOR. WE CAN
USE THAT SAME RESERVOIR THEY
WERE USING TO DRIVE ALL THESE
ENERGY SECTORS TO PROVIDE THE
SEASONAL STORAGE FOR THE POWER
SECTOR- AND THEN FINALLY THE
OTHER SOLUTIONS I THINK THE
OBVIOUS THING TO DO IS TO USE
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY SOURCES.
THAT ARE BUILT OUT AT A LEVEL
THAT WILL ALSO MEET NOT JUST
OUR CURRENT- ELECTRICITY LOADS.
BUT ALSO THE NEW LOADS LIKE
ELECTROLYSIS AND SOME OF THOSE
LOADS HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY-
AND SO WE DON'T NEED TO AND
MAYBE. USE THEM AS FREQUENTLY
BUT WE CAN- COUPLE TOGETHER THE
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY WITH THE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT THESE HUGE
LOADS CAN GREATLY REDUCE THE
SIZE OF THE SEASONAL STORAGE WE
NEED. I'M AND THANK YOU IT'S A
REAL PLEASURE- TO BE HERE LET
ME SEE IF I CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO. CONSTRUCTION I'M THANK YOU
AND AGAIN- I- URGE- STUDENTS-
PEOPLE GOING TO SCHOOL TODAY.
TO DEFINITELY TALK TO DOCTOR
KURTZ- AN EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN-
AND EXTRAORDINARY- PROJECT. SO
MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE THE
FIRST ONE UP TO ASK A QUESTION.
I HAVE SOME OF MY QUESTIONS
OVER THERE SO I MAY ASK AGAIN.
YES GOOD MOVE BACK AND FORTH
ANYTIME BUT LET ME LET I FIFTY
EIGHT GET THAT SHE SHE THE
DOCTOR ANSWERED ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS WHICH WAS THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF WHAT'S THE QUANTITY
OF. OF STORAGE NEEDED AND SO
YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE GIVEN UP
THE BASIC PARAMETERS LOOKING
FOR THEIR- A QUESTION I HAVE
THOUGH ABOUT THE HYDROGEN I'M
INTRIGUED- BY THE IDEA OF.
PRODUCING HYDROGEN WHEN YOU
HAVE THE EXCESS SOLAR BECAUSE
THEN. IT'S NOT AS COSTLY IN
THAT SITUATION IS THERE ANY
PROBLEM WITH LONG TERM STORAGE
OF HYDROGEN. YES STORAGE OF
HYDROGEN IS A BIG DEAL HOWEVER
THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
USING UNDERGROUND STORAGE. MUCH
LIKE WHAT WE'RE USING NATURAL
GAS UNDERGROUND STORAGE THERE'S
THE POSSIBILITY OF USING THAT
SAME TYPE OF LOW COST STORAGE
THERE AND THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO.
ESPECIALLY IN UTAH THERE'S A
BIG PROJECT DOING THAT NOW AS
LONG AS WE'RE USING OUR
UNDERGROUND STORAGE FOR NATURAL
GAS IT MAY BE MORE DIFFICULT
BUT EVENTUALLY. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP THE RESOURCES
WE NEED TO DO THE UNDERGROUND
STORAGE. SO BE SIDE UNDERGROUND
STORAGE IS THERE I MEAN DOES
HYDROGEN SIMPLY HYDROGEN IN A
TANK OF LAST FOR SIX MONTHS OR-
A YEAR CAN AT LAST THAT LONG OR
IS THERE SOME LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME HYDROGEN CAN LAST. I
REALLY DON'T KNOW I DON'T HAVE
AN- BASIC IDEA ON THAT AT ALL.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THREE PRIMARY WAYS
TO STORE HYDROGEN. ONE IS YOU
CAN STORE IT UNDER HIGH
PRESSURE. AND IF YOU GO INTO
THE UNDERGROUND CAVERN YOU WILL
PUT IT UNDER PRESSURE- YOU CAN
ALSO THEN WHEN YOU TAKE IT OUT
WHEN YOU PUT IT SAY INTO A
VEHICLE OR TO TRANSPORT IT
AROUND YOU CAN PUT IT IN A
CYLINDER WHERE IT'S UNDER HIGH
PRESSURE. ANOTHER AT THE OTHER
EXTREME IS TO LIQUEFY IT AND OF
COURSE AS A CRYOGENIC LIQUID.
SO IF YOU HAVE A WELL SEALED
VESSEL THE HIGH PRESSURE CAN
LAST FOR A LONG TIME THE
LEAKAGE RATES CAN BE QUITE LOW.
IF YOU HAVE THE CRYOGENIC
LIQUID IT GETS MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
KEEP THE TEMPERATURE LOS. SO
YOU WILL SEE THAT YOU EITHER
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO CHILL IT SO
THAT IT DOESN'T WARM UP AND
BOIL AWAY. OR YOU WILL HAVE.
SOME LOSS WITH THE LIQUID
HYDROGEN. NOW THE THIRD ONE
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING IS THAT
THERE IS. THE POSSIBILITY OF
USING A METAL HYDRIDE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHERE YOU
CAN STORE IT AND EFFECTIVELY
ROOM TEMPERATURE OR JUST A
LITTLE BIT BELOW ROOM
TEMPERATURE. AT A SOMEWHAT
ELEVATED PRESSURE. AND THEN
WHEN YOU WANT TO BRING IT OUT
YOU WARM IT UP A LITTLE BIT AND
THEN- TAKE IT OUT. AT A
PRESSURE THAT'S CLOSER AND
THAT'S A MUCH LOWER PRESSURE
THAN WHAT YOU WOULD USE IN A
BIG CYLINDER. THAT TECHNOLOGY
IS NOW BEING COMMERCIALIZED AND
IT'S AGAIN IN MORE OF A
DEVELOPMENT STAGE. IT MAY BE
MORE DIFFICULT TO SCALE BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO GET A LOT OF- METAL
HYDRIDE MATERIAL BUT IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL. TO ALSO GIVE YOU
SOME LOCAL STORAGE WHICH MAKES
IT EASIER IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN
UNDERGROUND CAVERN CITY
UNDERGROUND. I'M I'M INTERESTED
BUT THEN A LITTLE WHILE TO.
BURDEN YOU WHICH I DIDN'T GET
INTO ALL OF THE REST OF THIS
RIGHT NOW GIVEN OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS BUT- I'M INTERESTED
IN THE IN. TRYING TO SEE HOW
MUCH VARIETY WE CAN CREATE AND
STORAGE OPTIONS FOR HYDROGEN-
IF IT IS GOING TO BE A- AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE FORCED A MORE
VARIETY WE HAVE IN TERMS OF
STORY UP STORAGE OPTIONS.
OBVIOUSLY THE MORE APPLICABLES
DALY THE ENERGY SOURCE COULD
BE. AND COULD BE USED AND COULD
BE APPLIED GEOGRAPHICALLY
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. I'D AND I'D LOOK
REALLY LIKE TO ADD THEIR I
REALLY INTRIGUING WHEN THERE'S
SO MANY INNOVATIONS OUT THERE
ONE IS THAT YOU CAN TAKE AN OLD
OIL WELL. AND YOU CAN- CAP OFF
THE PART OF THE WELL THAT IS.
INTO THE POOREST ROCK SO THAT
YOU CAN SEAL IT UP AND THEN YOU
CAN USE THAT SHAFT THAT'S USED
IN THE OIL WELL. AS A WAY OF
STORING THE HYDROGEN. AND SO
IT'S ACTUALLY SOME OF THE OIL
COMPANIES ARE INTERESTED IN
BEING ABLE TO- YOU SAID YOU CAN
EITHER. USE THEM TO STORE THE
HYDROGEN OR YOU CAN PUT A BIG
WEIGHT AND INTO A GRAVITY
STORAGE AND ACTIVE. IN IT IF
YOU IF YOU USE IN THE STORE THE
HYDROGEN. YOU HAVE TO DO IT
UNDER PRESSURE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO REFRIGERATE OR YOU HAPPEN
TO. GREAT IT'S AS LONG AS JUST
UNDER PRESSURE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO REFRIGERATE. THAT'S RIGHT
GREAT THANK YOU OKAY THANK. I
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT- OF
THE T. F. MISTER CALDERON. YEAH
ALL RIGHT ARM. THE SO I HAVE
SOME- CLARIFICATION SO WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT 1% OF THE ANNUAL
LOAN FIRST OF ALL DURING THE
WINTER TIME IN CALIFORNIA R.
WELL DURING THE SUMMER OUR
MAXIMUM POWER AND AGAIN PEOPLE
GET CONFUSED BETWEEN POWER AND
ENERGY SO THE AMOUNT OF POWER
WE GENERATE. AT PEAK IS AROUND
FIFTY GIGAWATTS. AND JUST KNOW
THAT THE NUMBER IS FIFTY IT'S A
BIG NUMBER. BOB PROBABLY THE
AVERAGE FOR THE YEAR IS I DON'T
KNOW WE'LL WE'LL JUST DO THIS
SAY FORTY. SOMETHING LIKE THAT-
FORTY GIGAWATTS. AND SO ONE
WELL YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO
GENERATE POWER ON THE ORDER OF
TENS OF GIGAWATTS DURING THE
WINTER MARC MOST LIKELY
DEPENDING ON. HI THE EXTENT TO
WHICH YOU MIGHT HAVE GEOTHERMAL
OR SOMETHING ELSE IT'S BASE
LOAD BUT THE LACK OF SOLAR
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO DATE ON
THE ORDER OF TEN OR SO
GIGAWATTS. OF POWER. AND YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE AMOUNT OF
STORAGE SO. THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY WE USE IS. FORTY
GIGAWATT TIMES THE NUMBER OF
TIMES THE TIME IN A YEAR. 1% IS
ABOUT THREE DAYS- OF THAT SO
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT.
GENERATING TENS OF GIGAWATTS
FOR THE EQUIVALENT OF. SO THREE
DAYS TIMES- FORTY AROUND A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY GIGAWATT
HOURS- OF STORAGE THAT'S THAT'S
A HUGE NUMBER. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY HOW BIG THAT IS- YOU
KNOW ALL THE HYDRO WE HAVE IN
THE STATE IS YOU KNOW. IF YOU
GET A LOT- AND IT RUNS. FOR- A
MONTH OR TWO- LET'S SAY SIXTY
DAYS YOU KNOW. YES THE NUMBERS
ARE JUST OFF THE SCALE COMPARED
TO ANYTHING ELSE WE DO AND
YOU'RE ALSO POINTING OUT. THAT
THE ECONOMICS IS SUCH THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE AS
WITH NATURAL GAS SOME AMOUNT
THAT'S JUST THERE FOR SECURITY
THAT YOU PROBABLY NEVER WILL
YEARS. AND THEN AN AMOUNT.
WHICH YOU WILL USE WHICH IS
ALREADY A LARGE NUMBER. AND
JUST GET PEOPLE USED TO THE
IDEA THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCALES THAT WE JUST DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT. THE END QUESTION IS
GOING TO BE WHAT'S THE CHEAPEST
WAY TO DO THIS. AND THERE ARE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT THERE
JUST WASN'T TIME TO GET INTO.
BUT PART OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
EFFICIENCY. SO LET'S SAY YOU'RE
STORING HYDROGEN- NOT QUITE BUT
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU ELECTROLYSIS
EYES WATER INTO HYDROGEN OR
WHAT'S THE EFFICIENCY OF THAT
APPROXIMATELY. SO IT CAN VARY
BUT- YOU MAY HAVE AN EFFICIENCY
JUST FOR THEIR THE CONVERSION
TO HYDROGEN CAN BE APPROACHING
SOMETHING LIKE 70% 70% AND THEN
AT THAT. IF WE CAN GET AND THEN
THE BEST. CONVERTING IT BACK
INTO ELECTRICITY YOU'RE GOING
TO GET MORE LOSSES PROBABLY
ANOTHER THAT PASSED ANOTHER 70%
EFFICIENCY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
A LOSS OF ABOUT HALF. OF THE
ENERGY IS GENERATED JUST FOR
AND IT MAY BE THE ROUND TRIP
EFFICIENCY WILL PROBABLY
BETWEEN 30% AND 50% FOR THE
HYDROGEN. AND FOR THE OTHERS-
THAT YOU MENTIONED TO THE-
COMPRESSED AIR IS ROUND TRIP
THE COMPRESSED AIR WILL BE
LOWER IF THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
MAKE MORE LIKE 65% THE- THE
QUICK NAPS APPROACH WITH THE GM
MECHANICAL MAY BE ABLE TO
APPROACH. I'M MORE LIKE 75%
EIGHTY PERCENT. SEVENTY FIVE OR
80% I NEED TO TRANSFER. ALL
RIGHT BUT IT'S HIGHER THAN IT
SHOULD BOTH OF. ENJOYING HIGHER
THAN HYDROGEN ARM. AGAIN GET A
HOUSE EXPENSIVE IS IT GONNA BE
TO. OUR STORE ANY OF THESE BUT
OUR- THERE'S A LOT WE NEED TO
DO WE WERE GOING TO NEED TO
HAVE THESE PLANTS AND ONE OF
THE THINGS I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH IS THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
DOING THIS NOW. AND THAT IS
GREAT- THERE WILL OF COURSE BE
QUESTIONS ABOUT BY THE WAY NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO WE WILL NEED
HYDROGEN FOR SOME THINGS
PARTICULARLY INDUSTRIAL AREN'T
THAT INDUSTRIAL- ELEMENT SO WE
WILL BE PRODUCING HYDROGEN
WHETHER IT'S USED FOR STORAGE
OR SOMETHING ELSE- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. YES MISTER
BENNETT. GOOD. I WANT TO LOWER
THE RATE HI THIS. IS. I THEY
ARE OFTEN LEFT AFTER
TRANSPORTATION. RECITED AS WE
GET MORE OUT. I'M SORRY I'M A
START OVER AGAIN BECAUSE YOU
COULDN'T HEAR I COULD SEE YOU
LEADING AND I DIDN'T HAVE MY-
MICROPHONE BECAUSE HYDROGEN HAS
A LOWER EFFICIENCY RATE. THAN
THE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED IT- AT SIXTY
FIVE AND PROTECT SEVENTY FIVE
TO POTENTIALLY EIGHTY. WHILE IT
HAS A LOWER EFFICIENCY RATE IT
HAS A GREATER APPLICABILITY TO
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER ITEMS
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEG PRODUCING
THAT ANYWAY. SO I WOULD BE
CURIOUS OF SOME KIND OF
ANALYSIS OF THE ECONOMIES OF
OF CREATING THE HYDROGEN. WELL
IF YOU'RE GONNA GO TO THE
TROUBLE OF TRADING IT FOR OTHER
THINGS DONE WHAT'S THE MARGINAL
COST OF CREATING SOME MORE FOR
STORAGE FOR. OF THE ELECTRIC
GRID VERSES. INVESTING IN A NEW
TECHNOLOGY OR AYE AYE AYE WHICH
COME FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
RESILIENCY AND WHAT HAVE SOME
OF ALL BUT- BUT- THAT WILL THAT
PART OF THE ANALYSIS WOULD BE
SOMETHING I'D BE INTERESTED IN.
DOWN THE ROAD AND I KNOW YOU
CAN'T GET INTO ALL THAT RIGHT
NOW BUT- IN MY ACCURATE THAT
THERE WOULD BE MORE
APPLICATIONS AT THIS POINT IN
TIME IT LOOKS LIKE THE HYDROGEN
AND THE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES.
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES. THANK I
BELIEVE AND THAT'S DEFINITELY
TRUE AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU A FUN VISION JUST TO
STIMULATE YOUR INNOVATION I
THINK THE FUTURE IS GOING TO BE
VERY DEPENDENT UPON. THE EXTENT
TO WHICH WE CAN INNOVATE AND
COME UP WITH DIFFERENT IDEAS.
LET'S SAY THAT WE USE HYDROGEN
TO- DRIVE ARE BIG TRUCKS THAT
GO ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
OTHER TRUCK THEN CAN LOAD UP
WITH A BIG LOAD OF HYDROGEN
THEY COULD EVEN POTENTIALLY BE
A TRUCK THAT CARRIES HYDROGEN
AROUND IN LARGE QUANTITIES. AND
THEY HAVE A FUEL CELL ON BOARD
THAT'S USED TO CONVERT THE
HYDROGEN. TO ELECTRICITY IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE TRUCK GO. IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A SITUATION
LIKE WHAT TEXAS HAD OR LIKE IF
NEXT WEEK WE GOT A HUGE- HEAT
STORM ACROSS ALL OF THE WESTERN
AND- CALIFORNIA WAS HAVING
DIFFICULTY. IF YOU'RE A TRUCK
DRIVER YOU MEMBER IN TEXAS THEY
WERE PAYING NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MEGAWATT HOUR- WOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO LOAD YOUR
TRUCK UP WITH HYDROGEN AND THEN
DRIVE DOWN THERE AND THEN HOOK
YOUR FUEL CELL UP TO THE GREAT
AND USE THE VEHICLE TO GREAT
KIND OF CONCEPT. I CALL IT A
TICKER PLANT ON WHEELS. I'M
MOST OF THE TIME YOU'RE JUST
USING THAT TRUCK TO. DELIVER
OTHER GOODS. BUT THAT TRUCK NOW
COULD BE USED TO DRIVE THE
GREAT IN A PINCH AND IF YOU
PAID SOMEBODY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MEGAWATT HOUR THINK
THEY GO HOOK UP THE TRUCK AND
TAKE A NAP- WELL THE- RECENT
RESTOCK THE GREAT WITH
ELECTRICITY AND CAN STAND
CHARGE UP THE LITHIUM BATTERIES
AND THINGS THAT ARE SITTING
THERE. I'M GLAD YOU PUT THAT IS
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE- BEEN INTRIGUED ABOUT IS
THAT HYDROGEN CAN MOVE. FAIRLY
EASILY. BY TRUCK TO TWO PLACES
WHERE IT IS NEEDED RIGHT AND-
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT QUESTION
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- I
OFTEN TALKED HIS PHD IN
ASTROPHYSICS I TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT GOING TO SCHOOL AND WHAT
IS IT YOU REALLY WANT TO DO AND
AGAIN. CONSIDER UC MERCED JUST
SAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PROFESSOR AND WILL GO ON
TO THE NEXT PANEL. CHAU OUR
NEXT PANEL WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM EXPERTS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF COMMERCIALIZING
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THREE
PEOPLE- ALEX MORRIS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE. A DOCTOR SCOTT BURGER
FROM A FOUR BANERJEE WILL TALK
TO US ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
TAKING ENERGY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES FROM OUR ANTI-
THREE DEVELOPMENT. AND FINALLY
WE'RE GOING TO BE JOINED BY DR
RAVI UP PRESSURE FROM LAWRENCE
BERKELEY LAB TO SHARE WITH US.
HOW TO RAPIDLY SCALE INNOVATIVE
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES
EACH ONE OF THESE WILL SPEAK
FOR SEVEN MINUTES- ALEX MORGAN
ALEX. MORRIS COMES FROM US
AGAIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE- HE HAS TREMENDOUS
EXPERIENCE HAVING WORKED AT OF
THE CALIFORNIA- INDEPENDENT
SYSTEMS OPERATOR THAT OPERATES
ARE GRADED- THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION FOR. AND
OTHER ENERGY AND OTHER-
AGENCIES SO COMES TO US WITH A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE AND- WORKED
IN THE PLUG IN VEHICLES RATE
DESIGN SMART GRAY A DIALECTIC
TRANSPORTATION. RENEWABLE
INTEGRATION MARKET DESIGNED
STORAGE- LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA
STORAGE INITIATIVE AT CETERA ET
CETERA. SO- HE HAS- HE'S WORKED
FOR ELECTRICAL UTILITIES
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
HAS AN MBA FROM UC DAVIS. SO
MISTER MORRIS- PLEASE JOIN US.
I SOMEWHERE REQUIRE CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YEAH YEAH RIGHT WELL
I EVERYONE AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY IT'S GREAT TO JOIN
YOU AND I AGAIN I COME FROM A
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE AND IF IT'S OKAY I'LL
SHARE A FEW SLIDES JUST TO
GUIDE MY REMARKS. YEAH YES
THANK CURRENTLY NOT ABLE TO
SHARE CONTENT WHICH IS PROBABLY
OKAY I CAN WING IT- YEAH BUT IF
THAT GETS ACTIVATED ALL PULL UP
THE SLIDES. SO AGAIN C. SAYS
THE VOICE OF ENERGY STORAGE IN
CALIFORNIA IRAN'S. WE REPRESENT
ABOUT A HUNDRED MEMBERS ALL OF
WHOM ARE VERY ACTIVELY ENGAGED
IN STORAGE MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE MY SLIDES NOW. OKAY.
YEAH AND- SO YEAH WE'RE A
NONPROFIT TRADE ASSOCIATION
THAT'S VERY ACTIVE IN ALL OF
THE MAJOR AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE-
MARKET IS ONE OF THE LARGEST IN
THE WORLD IN SO AS WE GO
FORWARD AND FIGURE THINGS OUT
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO SUPPORT
IN SB ONE HUNDRED WERE OFTEN ON
THE FRONT LINES IT NAVIGATING
PROBLEMS THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
DEALT WITH A GREAT EXAMPLE IS
HEARING FROM GAVE EARLIER AT
THE CASE SO ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
DEVELOPING MARKET PARTICIPATION
PATHS FOR ENERGY STORAGE. AND
BUILDING A LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
AND HOW THESE RESOURCES WILL
PERFORM IN A VERY COMPLICATED
ENERGY MARKET OPTIMIZATION SO
IT'S ALWAYS FUN TO BE HERE BUT
THEN OCCASIONALLY WE ALSO WORK
WITH FEDERAL REGULATORS AND
FEDERAL ENERGY POLICY MATTERS
TO HELP BRING THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY- ALONG THIS JOURNEY-
AND THAT CALIFORNIA'S OFTEN
LEADING IN- THIS IS A MEMBERS
TYPICALLY ARE REALLY. THE MOST
SERIOUS AND SOPHISTICATED
ENERGY PLAYERS IN THE WORLD
AND- TO DOCTOR KURTZ IT WAS
GREAT TO. SEE YOU- YOUR TAKE ON
SO MANY OF THE SEASON MEMBERS
INCLUDING HIVE YOU AND HIGH
RESTORING QUITE IN THAT- AND WE
HAVE HYDROGEN MEMBERS AND MANY
MEMBERS WHO ARE FOCUSING ON IT
AND I SHARE THIS SLIDE BECAUSE-
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
CALIFORNIA'S DOING WELL AT IS.
CREATING MARKETS AND IS
DEFINING NEEDS FOR THE ELECTRIC
SYSTEM AND THEN THE STORAGE
COMPANIES AND THIS IS HOW SEIZE
OPERATES WE WANT THEM TO
COMPETE SO WE BASICALLY HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND. THE CALIFORNIA
MARKET AND TO THE EXTENT
APPROPRIATE AS INDUSTRY WE TRY
TO HAVE A VOICE HERE BUT THEN
WE EXPECT THEM TO SHOW UP AND
COMPETE AND DELIVER GOOD
COMPETITIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS. SO
THESE REALLY ARE THE MEMBERS
THAT AND IT'S A GREAT PRIVILEGE
TO WORK AND I WANT TO TELL YOU
ALL AS MEMBERS OF OUR
LEGISLATURE HOW IMPORTANT YOUR
WORK IS BECAUSE- EACH ONE OF
THESE COMPANIES IS. VERY
FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA THEY KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA IS A PLACE THAT
THEY CAN AND SHOULD FOCUS ON
FOR BUSINESS. AND SO THEY'RE
TRULY DEPLOYING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. TO GEAR UP IN PROVIDE
SERVICES HERE AND THAT COMES
FROM YOUR POLICY SIGNALS. SO
IT'S AN IMPORTANT SIGNAL THAT
YOU CREATE THEN INDUSTRY IS
RESPONDING. I THOUGHT AS I GET
INTO WHAT THE COMMERCIALIZATION
CHALLENGES ARE I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE I THINK THIS IS
BEEN CLEAR THAT. THAT THE SCALE
OF STORAGE NEEDS IN THE SCALE
OF THIS PROBLEM ARE MASSIVE
JUST TRULY MASSIVE. AND IN A
SINGLE DECISION. THIS YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DIRECTED PROCUREMENT
OF RESOURCES THAT WILL INCLUDE
STORAGE. AND NOT SINGLE
DECISION WAS BIGGER THAN IT
WASN'T AMOUNT BIGGER THAN MANY
UTILITIES IN THE COUNTRY SO OUR
SINGLE DECISION FOR- ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS. IS BIGGER THAN THE
ENTIRE UTILITY OF LADWP SO THAT
GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE SCALE.
OF HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ADDING
STORAGE WE'RE GONNA BE ADDING
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
STORAGE PER YEAR. AND I SHARE
ALL OF THIS BECAUSE AS WE LOOK
AT THE COMMERCIALIZATION WHAT I
THINK THIS- COMMITTEE SHOULD
FOCUS ON PARTICULAR WITH
SEASONAL STORAGE IS THAT. WE
HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM. TAKE YOUR
OUT FOR AND WE'RE GONNA BE
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY ON IT
AS CALIFORNIANS AND I OF COURSE
LIVE HERE AND SO YOU KNOW I
REALLY WANT US TO MAKE SURE THE
TOOL KIT IS READY AND SO-
SOMETHING OR PERHAPS SHOULD THE
CHANCE TO FOCUS ON. COME
DEALING WITH THE VALLEY OF
DEATH AND REALLY WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS GETTING THE TOOL KIT
READY SO THAT WE HAVE ALL OF
THESE. TECHNOLOGIES READY TO
COMPETE WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
BRING COSTS DOWN WHEN IT COMES
TIME FOR US TO REALLY BE
BUYING. SO THIS IS A SMART AND
TIMELY MATTER AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO PARTICIPATE. REALLY FROM THE
INDUSTRY SIDE I WANT TO TELL
YOU THOUGH. IT IS TOUGH TO GO
FROM SMALL SCALE ARE INDEED TO-
BIG SCALE AND WE HAVE MANY OF
THESE COMPANIES THAT ARE
JOCKEYING TO PROVIDE SERVICES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. YET BECAUSE
THEY ONLY HAD A FEW. BITES AT
THE APPLE OR A FEW PROJECTS IN
THE GROUND THEY DON'T YET HAVE.
EVERYTHING TUNED AND THAT'S
WHAT I MEAN BY EVERYTHING I
MEAN. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BANKS. READY TO LEND TO THEM AT
COMPETITIVE PRICES BECAUSE THE
BANKS HAVEN'T SEEN THEIR
TECHNOLOGY PERFORM YET. THEY
DON'T HAVE THE INSURANCE
PROVIDERS. READY TO LET-
PROVIDES WARRANTY SERVICES OR
TO PUT TOGEHER AN INSURANCE
PACKAGE IN A MONTH. BECAUSE
OFTEN WHEN YOU'RE COMPETING TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE TO YOU PUT YOUR BITS
TOGETHER IN RESPONSE TO A
UTILITY OR A CCA. REQUEST FOR
OFFERS WITHIN. THIRTY TO SIXTY
DAYS AND SO IT'S HARD.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO HAVE ALL THEIR
DUCKS IN A ROW TO COMPETE SO
QUICKLY. AND SO- WORK WHERE I
GENERALLY LAND WITH THIS IS
THAT. YOU KNOW- MORE SUPPORT IS
NEEDED- THIS SLIDE HIGHLIGHTS
THAT. AS WE MOVE TOWARDS
DECARBONISATION THE NEEDS ARE
JUST SO BIG. THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE IT REALLY
SERIOUSLY AND SEE SAYS EVEN
STUDY THE CASE THAT DOCTOR KIRK
MENTIONED ABOUT- LOW SOLAR
RADIATION AND NO IN THE
WINTERTIME AND YOU HEARD- MR
MURDOCH FROM K. SO EMPHASIZE
THE NEED FOR WINTER. CAPABILITY
AND WE HAVE A STUDY THAT SHOWS-
YOU KNOW WILL NEED. TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF LONG
DURATION AND SEASONAL STORAGE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SENSITIVITY CASES WITH
GREENHOUSE GASES AND EXTREME
WEATHER. IT GETS EVEN MORE
SERIOUS. SO VERY QUICKLY AND I
LOOK FORWARD ANY QUESTIONS WHAT
I WOULD SUGGEST IS OUT OF FOCUS
ON THE TOOL KIT AND GETTING
EVERYONE READY TO COMPETE AS WE
GET INTO PRIME TIME. AND I
THINK OUR CC EPIC PROGRAM HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB OF THAT FOR
SMALLER. OBJECT BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO FOCUS NOW ON A GETTING
A DIVERSE TOOL KIT READY FOR
COMMERCIAL SCALE PROJECTS. AND
THAT OFTEN MEANS- HELPING THEM
OVERCOME THIS INITIAL GREEN
PREMIUM AND SCALING
TECHNOLOGIES AT FIVE TO TWENTY
FIVE MEGAWATTS ARE LARGER. AND
THEN ALSO LOOKING AT SOMEBODY'S
UP TECHNOLOGY DIVERSITY
BENEFITS IN ANTICIPATING THAT
THAT WILL BE VALUABLE TO US. IN
FINDING WAYS TO PROCURE-
SOMEBODY THAT TECHNOLOGY WE
DON'T HAVE VERY MUCH OF LIKE
THE VERY LARGE OR THE
ALTERNATIVE TECHNOLOGIES. WE
HEARD OF HIGH RESTORE HIVE YOU
IN QUICK NAP AND REALLY HELPING
FIND MARKET OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE. THERE'S OTHER WAYS WE
CAN DO THIS TOO IN THE ON THE
POLICY FRONT HERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT SO THAT'LL WRAP UP MY
REMARKS AND DR IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE THANK YOU. AND IT'S
I'LL JUST TAKE A MINUTE TO SAY
I'VE KNOWN ALEX SINCE HE
STARTED- REALLY STARTED THIS-
ASSOCIATION- HE IS- IN THE SAME
CALL HEART. CO HEART OF
IDEALISTIC PEOPLE LIKE MY SON
WHO WE KNEW WHAT PG&E. WHO ARE
OUT THERE MY SENSE NOW WITH
APPLE. TRYING TO CHANGE THE
WORLD- YOU KNOW I'M NOT GOING
TO BE AROUND WHEN THE WORST OF-
OF THE GLOBAL WARMING HITS US
IN ANOTHER TWENTY THIRTY YEARS
BUT- THESE GENTLEMEN WILL BE MY
SON. ALEX AND- THEY WANT A
DIFFERENT WORLD. AND WE HAVE TO
BE INSPIRED BY PEOPLE LIKE ALEX
WHO ARE. YOU KNOW STE STARTING
FROM NOTHING AND HELPING US
FINDER SOLUTIONS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALEX- WE WILL NOW
HAVE THE IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ARM I WILL. START
WITH OUR NEXT PERSON DR SCOTT
BURGER FROM FORM ENERGY IS TELL
US ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
TAKING THAT ENERGY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY FROM R. AND D.
THROUGH DEPLOYMENT FROM A START
UP PERSPECTIVE- JUST TO SAY A
FEW WORDS- HE IS BESIDES BEING
A SENIOR MANAGER AT- FOR
MANAGING AND LEADING THE
ANALYTICS TEAM- HE'S BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING AND
DELIVERING THE ELECTRICITY
MARKET AND PROJECT MODELING AND
DATA SCIENCE. THE POWERS FORMS
COMMERCIAL STRATEGY BATTERY
PRODUCT MANAGEMENT POLICY AND
REGULATORY AFFAIRS- AND HE WILL
AS A FELLOW AT THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM- GLOBAL FUTURE
COUNCIL ON ENERGY AND LECTURER
IN IT. M. I. T. ARM AND HIS
RESEARCH AT MIT FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING THE- EQUITY. OF THE-
TO DECENTRALIZED ENERGY SYSTEMS.
SO MISTER DOCTOR BERGER- PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORK AND- THE OTHER
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS PANELISTS
AND GUESTS IT'S REALLY GREAT TO
BE HERE. AND AS DR JUST
MENTIONED I READ OUR ANALYTICS
TEAM INFORM ENERGY AND SO OUR
TEAM BASICALLY BUILDS COMPUTER
MODELS AND USES TOOLS THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED IN HOUSE OR
EXTERNALLY TO HELP OURSELVES
AND OUR CUSTOMERS UNDERSTAND
AND COMMUNICATE THE VALUE OF
THE PRODUCT THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING- I'M GONNA START BY
INTRODUCING FOR MANAGING AND-
YOU KNOW WHO WE ARE AND- WHY
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND THEN I'M GONNA GET INTO
KIND OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT AS THIS PANEL SPOKE A
SIGN. THAT WE FACE AND
COMMERCIALIZING NEW AND LONG
DURATION OR MULTI DAY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES. AND THEN END WITH
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK ARE SOME
OF THE BENEFITS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACTING. THE SONGS
AND THESE CHALLENGES- SO A BIT
ABOUT FOR MANAGING YOU KNOW WHO
WE ARE WHY WE'RE HERE I FOR
MANAGING AS THE COMPANY WAS
FOUNDED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY
A SET OF INDUSTRY STORAGE
VETERANS SO FOLKS FROM
COMPANIES LIKE HAS LINE ACREE
ON AND- A ONE TWO THREE AND- I
TRY- INDUSTRIES AND YOU KNOW A
NUMBER OF OTHER I BASICALLY.
HAVE- STORY COMPANIES AND
ENERGY STORAGE SECTOR- AND
REALLY CAME TOGETHER TO SOLVE-
ONE CORE PROBLEM IS YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE COMMERCIALIZE
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPED AND
COMMERCIALIZED TECHNOLOGY THAT
ENABLES A FULLY ELECTRIC. ARE
FULLY RENEWABLE ELECTRIC CREDIT.
EXTENDED WEATHER EVENTS THESE
KIND OF EVENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT- THROUGHOUT THIS
THIS- SESSION. OUR FIRST
PRODUCT OUR FIRST COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT IS A RICH CHARGEABLE
IRON AIR BATTERY. THAT IS
CAPABLE OF CONTINUOUSLY
DISCHARGING ELECTRICITY FOR ONE
HUNDRED HOURS THAT'S A LITTLE
OVER FOUR DAYS. AT SYSTEM COST
COMPETITIVE WITH FOSSIL FUELED
POWER PLANTS. BY USING IRON
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
ABUNDANT AND REALLY CHEAPEST
MINERALS ON THE PLANET. OUR
SOLUTION WE THINK CAN HELP
ENABLE- COST EFFECTIVE A 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY GRID. OUR
TECHNOLOGY AGAIN OUR IRON AIR
BATTERIES A STATIC BATTERY
THAT'S NOT A FLOW BATTERY. I IT
DOESN'T INVOLVE KIND OF THE
PUMPING OF- OF. OPERATOR ERROR
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT LIKE SOME
OF THE OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
PANELISTS DISCUSSED- IN IN IN
YOUR BEING A BATTERY IS VERY
MODULAR SO YOU NOW WE DON'T
RELY ON SPECIFIC GEOLOGIC
FORMATIONS THAT MIGHT LIMIT-
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY LOCATE
THIS THING WE CAN WE CAN LOCATE
OUR BATTERY- ANYWHERE. AND BY
NATURE OF USING IRON AND OTHER
KIND OF- NON HAZARDOUS- ACHE WE
S. ELECTROLYTES AND OTHER
MATERIALS. IT'S VERY SAFE WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
THERMAL RUNAWAY PROBLEMS THAT
WITHIN MY OWN- TECHNOLOGIES HAS
OUR OUR BATTERIES CAN'T
SPONTANEOUSLY COMBUST OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT- AND AGAIN
IT'S VERY KIND OF-
GEOGRAPHICALLY. SCALABLE AND
MODULAR IN THAT SENSE- AND I
GUESS JUST TO KIND OF
UNDERSCORE WHY WE THINK. THAT
THIS IS AN INTERESTING
APPROACHES. IRON IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL KIND OF STORAGE
MEDIA FOR OUR TECHNOLOGY- AND
IRON BEING ONE OF THE CHEAPEST
AND MOST ABUNDANT MATERIALS ON
THE PLANET- PRODUCED YOU KNOW
IN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
TONS- GLOBALLY EACH YEAR ENOUGH
TO. PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF
GIGAWATTS OF OUR BATTERIES
EVERY YEAR AND- IT THE COST OF
STORING ENERGY IN THE IRON
MATERIALS IS VERY VERY WELL- TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF KIND OF
WHAT WE'RE TARGETING. WE EXPECT
OUR BATTERIES TO BE ABLE TO
STORE ENERGY AT LESS THAN ONE
TENTH UP SOME SURPRISING
APPROACHING ONE HUNDRED THE
COST OF TODAY'S LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES. SO YOU KNOW TO IT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRKS COMMENTS
EARLIER THIS REALLY IS KIND OF
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY-
GIVEN THAT IRAN AIR IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THIS THIS GROUP
IS PROBABLY DOT WITH BEFORE. I
JUST THAT THE TINY INTRODUCTION
ON THAT- ARE ARE BETTER YOU CAN
REALLY THINK OF IT AS IT IS A
REVERSIBLE RUST BATTERY SO ON
DISCHARGING OR WHEN WE'RE-
SENDING ELECTRICITY TO THE
GRID. IRON REACTS WITH OXYGEN
AND CREATES FROST GENERATES
ELECTRICITY. WHEN ARE CHARGING
THE BATTERY YEAH I RETURNS TO
ITS METALLIC STATE AND LEASES
OXYGEN SO THE ONLY KIND. OF
PRODUCT OF THAT REACTIVE OXYGEN-
WE DO SEE OURSELVES THE RIVER.
FOR WITHIN MY- RATHER WE SEE
OURSELVES A COMPLIMENT TO
LITHIUM ION- WE KIND OF LIKE TO
THINK OF OURSELVES AS WE KNOW
WHEN PAIRING WITH RENEWABLE
ENERGY. RENEWABLE ENERGY PLUS
OUR MULTI DAY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY CAN ENABLE KIND OF
BASELOAD. RENEWABLES AND
LITHIUM ION IS REALLY USEFUL AS
KIND OF A PEAKER BACKING ABOUT-
KIND OF REPLACING. SOME OF
TODAY'S REALLY. QUICK ACTING
BUT SHORT RUNNING- NATURAL GAS
PLANTS. WHERE WE ARE IN OUR
COMMERCIALIZATION PHASES WERE
IN THE PROTOTYPING PHASE. SINCE
WE BOUGHT OUR FIRST GET A SELL
ON TEST IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
HAVE SCALED OURSELVES ALMOST
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND TIMES SO WE
ARE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND TIMES
LARGER THAN WE WERE- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
BUILT NOW THE WORLD'S LARGEST-
BATTERY CELL INTERNS ENERGY
CAPACITY. WE EXPECT OUR FIRST-
PROJECTS DEPLOYED ON THE GRID
WITH MINNESOTA'S SECOND LARGEST
ELECTRIC UTILITY IT'S A UTILITY
COLOR GREAT RIVER ENERGY. AND
THIS PROJECT WILL BE A ONE
MEGAWATT ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MEGAWATT HOUR OR A HUNDRED
FIFTY HOUR BATTERY- THAT WILL
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY
DEMONSTRATE THAT KIND OF
REPEATABLE AND SCALABLE WALK OF
OUR SYSTEM. WE'RE NOW ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EMPLOYEES
AND WHILE ARE HEADQUARTERED IN
SOMERVILLE MASSACHUSETTS OUR
OUR SECOND LARGEST OFFICE IS IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW NOT BY
SURPRISES- ALEX JUST MOMENTS
AGO MENTIONED- YOU KNOW WE ARE
CHOOSING TO SCALE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE REALLY
THE SUPPORTIVE POLICY
ENVIRONMENTS ALL OF THAT KIND
OF ENGINEERING TALENT THAT IS
DEVELOPED THERE OVER THE YEARS
AS- THE STATE HAS DEVELOPED A
REALLY VIBRANT. RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND ENERGY STORAGE
SECTOR- SO THAT'S A BIT ABOUT
FORM. YOU KNOW. I THINK I'M
GONNA TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE- YOU KNOW ADDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY'S BATTERY TECHNOLOGY
LITHIUM ION. I HAVE REALLY KIND
OF SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
BALANCING INTRADAY OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY VERY ABILITY SO WE ARE
REALLY GOOD TODAY AT MOVING
ENERGY FROM NOON WE HAVE A LOT
OF SOLAR POWER. INTO MAYBE THE
EVENING PEAK HOURS- WHEN THIS
YOU KNOW THE SUN IS STARTING TO
SET THE DEMAND IS STILL REALLY
HIGH PEOPLE ARE ARE FLIPPING ON
YOUR TELEVISION CETERA. HOWEVER
IN THE FUTURE. WELL I BELIEVE
CHALLENGES WILL NOT BE DRIVEN
BY THESE PIZZA MAN HOURS RATHER
RELIABILITY CHALLENGES IN THE
FUTURE WE REALLY BE DRIVEN- BY
KIND OF CONTINUOUS MULTI DAY
PERIODS OF LOW RENEWABLE ENERGY
GENERATION. I JUST THAT THAT
KIND OF. SAY THAT THIS IS NOT
JUST MY OPINION- THAT THE
CONSULTANCY E. THREE. WHICH IS-
CONSULTANCY BASED IN IN
CALIFORNIA- THAT DOES A LOT OF
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO RUN ITS
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS USE OF THE PROCESSES
THAT WE USE TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED ON THE
GROUND- SAID IN A PAPER.
FOCUSING ON ON DEEP
DECARBONIZATION CALIFORNIA
THAT. AND I QUOTE. IN A SYSTEM
WHERE MOST GENERATIONS
INTERMITTENT. LOSS OF LOAD
EVENTS DON'T NECESSARILY
OCCURRED DURING HIGH LOAD
CONDITIONS RATHER. THE BIGGEST
DRIVER IS THE POTENTIAL FOR
MULTI DAY PERIODS OF LOW
RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION.
DURING THESE EVENTS RENEWABLE
GENERATION MAY BE INSUFFICIENT
TO SERVE ALL LOAD AND STORAGE
QUICKLY DEPLETES. SO THIS MULTI
DAY RENEWABLE ENERGY WALL IS D.
KEOGH ALL ARE THE KEY PROBLEM.
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO SOLVE.
AND WE'VE DONE OUR OWN ANALYSIS
ON THIS ISSUE WE EXAMINED
MEETING FOR MANAGING EXAMINED
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY DATA. THAT WAS PROVIDED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THROUGH
THE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROCESS- AND WE LOOKED
AT YOU KNOW WHAT DOES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY MIX WORK LIKE
IN TWENTY THIRTY. USING THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF DATA WE FOUND
THAT. FIFTY OUR RENEWABLE
ENERGY LEVELS OCCUR EVERY OTHER
YEAR SO MANY EVERY OTHER YEAR
ON AVERAGE YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
A FIFTY OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
SHORTFALL. AND ONE HUNDRED OUR
BALLS OCCUR ABOUT ONCE EVERY
TEN YEARS. AT THE LONGEST WELL
THAT WE FOUND IN THIS PERIOD
WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
HOURS. ACTUALLY WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE RELIABILITY CHALLENGE
THAT OF THE FUTURE AND THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE. IT'S NOT REALLY A
SEASONAL CHALLENGES ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO RELIABLY PROVIDE POWER
DURING THESE MULTI DAY PERIODS
OF LOW RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION. I THINK THIS
ANALYSIS IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THIS IS NOT A
TWENTY FIFTY PROBLEM. THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE FOUND IN
LOOKING AT THE TWENTY THIRTY
CALIFORNIA ENERGY NEXUS IS
REALLY ONE PLANNING. CYCLE AWAY-
SO THIS IS OF A PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE GOING AFTER I AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS NOT SO EASY
TO JUST SAY THIS IS THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE WANT TO
COMMERCIALIZE AND THEREFORE ALL
IS GOOD RIGHT THAT THAT'S THE
REASON WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY- OF
COURSE- COMMERCIALIZING AND
NUCLEAR TECHNOLOGY IS HARD. I'M
THAT THE POWER SECTOR IS REALLY
CHARACTERIZED BY. MARION
CHANGED IN SOME CASES CENTURY
OLD THAT INCUMBENTS. AND THE
COST OF ELECTRICITY IS REALLY
WHAT THE POWER SECTOR HAS BEEN
MORE COST AND RELIABILITY
REALLY HAVE BEEN THE THINGS OF
THE POWER SECTOR HAS BEEN. I
KIND OF LASER FOCUS ON
OPTIMIZING FOR- FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT AS A RESULT OF
THAT THE COST OF ELECTRICITY
TODAY IS ABOUT ONE TWO HUNDRED.
ABOUT WHAT OF WHAT IT WAS ABOUT
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO. ASK THE
INDUSTRY IS REALLY USED TO KIND
OF. OPTIMIZING FOR SHORT RUN
COSTS- ABSENT ANY KIND OF
POLICY INTERVENTION IT DOESN'T
USUALLY DISTINGUISH BETWEEN-
THE ATTRIBUTES OF ELECTRICITY
AND THERE THERE ISN'T REALLY A
HISTORY OF PAYING A PREMIUM FOR
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES ARE FOR
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES IS
REALLY. LASER FOCUSED ON
MINIMIZING SHORT RUN COSTS. AND
THAT THE OTHER MAN THE OTHER
PART THAT I MENTION IT'S REALLY
LASER FOCUSED ON RELIABILITY. I
YOU KNOW SENT ELECTRICITY IS
VERY CENTRAL TO OUR MODERN
LIVES- AND IN ORDER TO OPERATE
THE GEAT RELIABLY ME AFTER
THESE BALANCING SUPPLY AND
DEMAND AT ALL IMES- AND
BECAUSE OF THAT DYNAMIC WE HAVE
BY TYPICALLY VERY RISK AVERSE-
ENTITIES SO INTO. YOU KNOW
BASICALLY COMPANIES THAT OUR
SUPPLIER POWER DON'T WANT TO
EXPERIMENT WITH THAT PROBLEM
SO. THAT WE HAVE THESE KIND OF
TWO PROBLEMS WE HAVE-
OPTIMIZING FOR REALLY SHORT RUN
COSTS ABOVE ALL ELSE AND
OPTIMIZING FOR RELIABILITY
ABOVE ALL ELSE- AND THIS IS A
BIG CHALLENGE WHEN YOU HAVE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT OFTEN START
OUT AS- MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THEIR INCUMBENTS. WITH OF
COURSE A PATHWAY TO BEING MUCH
CHEAPER BUT WHEN THE COMPANIES
ARE JUST GETTING LAUNCHED-
BECAUSE OF ALL THE REASONS THAT
ALEX AND OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED.
THEY MIGHT BE MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND ARE PERCEIVED NEW RISKS
RIGHT. AND IT'S THEIR PERCEIVED
ARRESTS WITH EAST ECOLOGY'S.
AND SO AGAINST THAT BACK
COMPANIES LIKE FOR ME G. HAVE
TO SCALE TO A POINT OF REALLY
HAVING HUNDREDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
CAPACITY ON THE GRID SO THEY
CAN BOTH BRING COSTS DOWN- AND
CONVINCE ALL OF THE FINANCIERS
AND OTHER ENTITIES THAT THESE
ARE REALLY LOW RISK
TECHNOLOGIES- I'M IN IN ORDER
TO DO THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
CAN YOU JUST SHUT UP AND WILL
TRY AND GET TO THE OTHERS
SPEAKERS. SO OKAY. AGUIAR-CURRY
OKAY GO AHEAD YEAH SO WHAT LONG
STORY SHORT TO GET THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING AT TECHNOLOGIES AND
INNOVATION- THIS IS DONE WITH
WHAT THE MRI ON PROVIDING LONG
TERM INVESTMENT SIGNALS THAT
REALLY I KIND OF FOCUS ON THE
DIFFERENT STAGES OF TECHNOLOGY
COMMERCIALIZATION SUPPORTING
DEMONSTRATION AT THE EARLIER
STAGES OF TECHNOLOGY
COMMERCIALIZATION. THAT HAS
REALLY LED TO THE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AYE THERE'S A REASON
THAT WE ARE HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I AND THERE'S A
REASON THAT THAT THE INDUSTRY
IS VERY ROBUST THERE- THIS IS
ALSO A PROBLEM THIS MONTH THAT
A PROBLEM IS SOMETHING THAT IS
THAT YOU THREE AND OTHERS I
FOUND THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO IN THE ACIFIC NORTHWEST
IN THE MIDWEST NORTHEAST UP
STATIC CALIFORNIA REALLY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD HERE
DEMONSTRATE A PATHWAY FOR
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM AND ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY- THAT CAN KIND OF
GROW IN CALIFORNIA AND THEN BE
EXPORTED TO- REALLY. PEOPLE
ELSEWHERE OKAY SO ARE AT THE
END OF THIS PANEL I'LL BE
ASKING- WHAT POLICIES MIGHT
HELP YOU ARE TO GET YOUR
VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDING WHICH I
SUSPECT YOU'RE GETTING- I'M
ALSO JUST JUST FOR THE MOMENT.
WHILE YOU'RE HERE. I SHOW YOUR-
RUSHED BASED BATTERY- FIRST ALL
FOR PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE THE
REASON WHY WE WENT WITH LITHIUM
AIR IS EXCUSE ME LET THE M. ION
IS THAT IT IS LIGHTWEIGHT. THE
THEMES ABOUT AS LIGHT AS YOU
CAN GET FOR AN ELEMENT THAT'S A
METAL- IT'S LIGHT WEIGHT AND
IT'S SMALL AND FOR OUR PHONES
IN OUR CARS THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
NOW IF YOU DON'T CHARGE A
LITHIUM ION BATTERY FOR A WEEK.
YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH TRACHSEL
HAFT- SO IF YOU JUST JUST
SITTING THERE IT'S JUST CHARGES
DO YOU DOES YOUR IRON BATTERY
DISCHARGE OVER THE PERIOD OVER
PERIOD OF TIME. YEAH IT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION- THAT THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES WE DO
EXPERIENCED SELF DISCHARGE. BUT
THAT THE REALITY IS WE DON'T
THAT OUR BATTERIES DON'T SIT
THERE AND SAID I DON'T RATHER
OUR BATTERIES ARE ACTUALLY VERY
ACTIVE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT KIND OF THE
LEAST COST THE COST MINIMIZING
MIX OF RESOURCES AND THE COST
MINIMIZING WAIT IT TOOK TO
OPERATE THESE ASSETS. WE
ACTUALLY SEE THAT WHILE WE ARE
PROVIDING SEASONAL STORAGE SO
WE MIGHT BE HAVING KIND OF-
CONSISTENT CHARGING OVER THE
OVER SPRING OR- FALL ME HAVE
ACCESS RENEWABLE ENERGY AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I AM KIND
OF NET DISCHARGE THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER THROUGHOUT THE WINTER WE
ACTUALLY SEE THAT- WE'RE REALLY
KIND OF OPERATING ON A DAILY
BASIS DOING SOME CHARGING SOME
DISCHARGING ON A DAILY BASIS. I
WE JUST HAPPEN TO BE CHARGING
MORE ON AVERAGE IN THOSE DAYS
DURING THE SPRING MORE ON
AVERAGE IN THOSE DAYS DURING
THAT THE FALL AND- YOU KNOW
LAST ON AVERAGE IN THOSE DAYS
IN THE WINTER- AND MUST MUST ON
AVERAGE DURING THE IN THOSE
DAYS IN THE SUMMER SO. I WE
ACTUALLY DON'T SEE VERY MANY
CARRIERS WERE JUST SITTING
AROUND DOING NOTHING AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THE SOUTH
DISCHARGED CHALLENGE ISN'T
REALLY KIND OF A COURT
CHALLENGE THAT ECONOMIC YEAH
BUT CAN YOU DO THAT AND STILL
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
DAYS OF RESERVE. BECAUSE I CAN
ASSURE YOU NO POLITICIAN WANTS
TO GO EVEN ONE DAY. WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY. SO CAN YOU DO ALL
THAT AND STILL HAVE A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE DAYS IN A RESERVE.
MOST OF WHICH. CHARGING
OCCURRED MONTHS AGO. I'M CAN
YOU MAYBE EXPLAIN WHAT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE DAYS
NUMBERS CAN. AB AS THE AMOUNT
OF TIME WHEN YOU FOUND THAT
THERE WAS. NOT ENOUGH SOLAR AND
WIND THAT'S A HUNDRED AND FORTY
HOURS. FORTY HOURS YES HUNDRED
FORTY HOURS SO ALL RIGHT SO
HUNDREDS OF **** THAT MAKES
MORE SENSE I'M SORRY A HUNDRED
AND FORTY HOURS NOT DAYS I
SHOULD HAVE CAUGHT MYSELF
THERE'S SO HUNDRED ORDER. YES
ONE OF IN ONLY THE THING THAT
THAT DRIVES HOW MUCH ENERGY WE
CAN START OUR BATTERY IS THE
THICKNESS OF OUR ELECTORATE OF
THE IRON ELECTRODES. SO IF WE
YOU KNOW BASICALLY A HUNDRED
HOURS IS THAT ESSENTIALLY ONE
LAYER THICK. AND IF WE WANT TO
MAKE IT TO OUR OUR TWO HUNDRED
HOUR BATTERY WE ESSENTIALLY
DOUBLE THE THICKNESS OF THE
ELECTRODE. AND SO ESSENTIALLY
PRODUCING LONGER DURATION
BATTERIES TO COVER THESE LONGER
DURATION EVENTS IS KIND OF A%
PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT CYCLE NOT A
FUNDAMENTAL- TECHNICAL
CHALLENGE SO YOU KNOW WHILE OUR
FIRST PRODUCT IS A HUNDRED HOUR
BATTERY BECAUSE WE THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE MARKET WILL BE IN
TWENTY. TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
THIRTY. FIVE THERE'S NO KIND O
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE THAT
PREVENTS US FROM.
COMMERCIALIZING EIGHT AT TWO
HUNDRED HOUR BATTERY OR A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOUR BATTERY
AND IN FACT WE ACTUALLY HAVE.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED FIFTY AND TWO
HUNDRED OUR BATTERIES ON TEST
AT OUR FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND- AND MESSAGES AND OVER THE
COURSE OF MARKET SHARE A MONTH.
HOW MUCH SELF DISCHARGE WOULD
THERE BE. IF YOU WEREN'T.
CONSTANTLY I KNOW YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE PUTTING ENERGY IN AND
ENERGY OUT ON A DAILY BASIS.
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HUNDRED OUR STORAGE FOR SOME
TIME IN THE WINTER- YOU CAN GET
OUR- YOU'RE GONNA HAVE LET'S
SAY. PUT SOME ENERGY AND A
LARGE AMOUNT LET'S SAY IN THE
IN THE FALL- AND YOU MAY BE
TAKING YOU TO HOUSE A FEW
MEGAWATT HOURS IN AND OUT BUT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE HUGE
RESERVE AND THE QUESTION IS CAN
YOU HAVE IT THERE THE HUGE
RESERVE FOR THE WINTER HUNDRED
HOURS WORTH FOUR. MONTHS YES
ABSOLUTELY AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
WE ARE WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING
ON A PROJECT FUNDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION. I
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE E.
THREE TO KIND OF DEMONSTRATE
HOW LONG DURATION STORAGE- CAN
OPERATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR BASICALLY
MODELING IN VERY MUCH DETAIL
THAT THE CALIFORNIA GRAD AND
LOOKING AT THESE TYPES OF
PROBLEMS I WAS ACTUALLY AT A
PROJECT THAT- THAT PROFESSOR
COURAGE IS ALSO FUNDED UNDER
SOMEWHERE WHERE CONNECT. I ONE
OF THE OTHER TEAMS THAT THAT IS
WORKING ON THE SAME THE SAME
CHALLENGE SO. TRANCERS YES AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT AND HAVE
KIND OF A LOT OF DETAILED
MODELING. SHARE ZERO EIGHT AND
A DEBT YEAH THE OTHER THING TO
SAY ABOUT THIS IS COMPARED TO
LITHIUM ION OF COURSE IT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT HEAVIER AND A
LOT BIGGER AND THAT'S FINE. YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT TRYING TO MAKE
PHONES OR OR CARDS- WE'RE DOING
UTILITY SCALE AND- IT'LL STILL.
IT'S AN AMAZING TECHNOLOGY ALL
RIGHT OUR FINAL SPEAKER OKAY.
IS SOMEONE THAT I'M I'M VERY
PLEASED TO JOIN ME IN THIS
DOCTOR REVY- SURE FROM LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB AND HE'S
GOING TO TALK TO US ABOUT HOW
TO RAPIDLY SCALE INNOVATIVE
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES.
AGAIN VERY DISTINGUISHED- AND A
GRADUATE OF THE INDIAN
INSTITUTE OF TECHNOLOGY IN
DELHI WHICH IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
INSTITUTION ARE TRULY ARRIVAL
WITH MIT OR CALTECH. AND A PHD
FROM ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY-
TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
WORKING IN OUR INDIAN LARGE
INDUSTRY START UP GOVERNMENT
ACADEMICS. AT CETERA SO- DR
BASHAR- PLEASE BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HAD CALLED I SHARE I
HAD MY SHARE MARTIN IS NOT.
ACTIVE SO I'M NOT SURE HOW I
CAN SHARE MY PRESENTATION. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OKAY. ALL RIGHT
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
SCREAM IS- IS COMING UP WE SEE
YEAR- WHAT WE SHE IS ON THE
LEFT THE LIST OF THE SLIDE YOU
AND THERE WE GO PERFECT. NOW
YOU'RE THERE. ONCE I'M SORRY MY
DAUGHTER THE START OF PARAMOUNT
I HAD WAS JUST GIVE ME A SECOND
OKAY. HEY WE ALL WORK AT HOME
THESE GET NOTHING. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR ALL THE SLIDES BE
AVAILABLE FOR OUR YES WE'RE
PLANNING TO ASK YOU TO THE
OFFICE FOR THE SLIDES AND WILL
DISTRIBUTE THEM TO ANYONE WHO'S
BEEN THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
GREAT CHAIRS AND VICE CHAIRS
OF- UTILITIES AND- ALSO LAW
NATURAL RESOURCES AND- ANYONE
ELSE SINCE YOU STOPPED BY THANK.
YES THIS IT WAS HARD TO- TAKE
ALL THOSE SLIDES IN. ALL RIGHT
UP SORRY WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE ONE OF THE THINGS OF
WORKING FROM HOME. YUP YOUR OF
FIRST ORDER GOT FIRED TODAY
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
VIDEOLAN COMMITTEE ON ART SHARE
MY TALKS ABOUT LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE. SO UNDER
PRESSURE I AND THIS IS A LOT
BETTER. THE TECHNOLOGY AREA AB
LAWS BUT LOST A LOT. RAMOS AN
EXAMPLE FACILITIES YOU BERKELEY
WHAT I TEACH COURSES IN
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING. GET TO
THE SLIDE HERE AND I'D BE HAVE
HARD FOR MANY OF US SPEAKERS
WHY LACK LONGER ISN'T STORED IS
VERY IMPORTANT. A FEW OF OUR
SCIENTISTS IN THE LAB THEY
ANALYZED. RADIUS AND ARTICLES
OF UNIVALENT OG. ARE YOU KNOW
80% VERY 30% SOLAR. A 50% AND
50% SOLAR ALONG. ADD AND
ASSUMING THAT YOU KNOW HAVE
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY SOMETIME
IN THE FUTURE. WHAT FRACTION OF
THE ENERGY STORAGE CAN BE LONG
DURATION STORAGE AND- THE BABY
ANIMALS IF I LONG RESISTED IS A
GREAT ANYTHING THAT AT THE TIME.
TEN HOURS TO DAY. WHAT
EVERYBODY'S. WHAT DO YOU FIND
OUT OF THIS ROBERT YOU SEE IS
ROUGHLY- PART OF THIS I'M SORRY
THIS LIABILITY DEADLINE IS
SHIFTED THE PRESENTATION BUT- A
67% THAT'S WHERE IT IS. ROUGHLY
TO POWER OFF. WELL NOT JUST
YOURS MEMBERS RIGHT HERE. I
DON'T HAVE HOURS TO UPDATE TO
TALK ABOUT THE OVERALL ENERGY
STORAGE REQUIREMENT. IT'S GOING
TO MORE THAN TEN HOURS GOOD.
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER. ANOTHER
DOPE FOR MANY OF US SPEAKERS
AND FROM BURGER CORD THAT GIVE
THEM UNDESERVEDLY GOOD
TECHNOLOGY FOR SHORT DURATION I
WOULD SAY BETWEEN FOUR TO SIX
HOURS GOOD. REALLY NOT A VERY
GOOD BECAUSE OF A TECHNOLOGY
FOR ANYTHING BEYOND THE NUMBERS
FOR SURE. EVEN ASSUMING VERY
CAUGHT AGGRESSIVE COST ARGUES
WITH HIM. AND THE LEADING
LONGER TECHNO LOGY SUCH A
PUMPED HYDRO COMPRESSED AIR
STORAGE. I'M SORRY REALLY NEED.
THAT'S WHY THERE IS. TO DOUBLE
UP A STATE COST EFFECTIVE.
JOGADOR FICA THE INDEPENDENT
LONG RESISTANCE TO. RIGHT AND
THAT'S RIGHT YOU KNOW MRS YEP
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION IF
IT'S- BUT HERE IS ANOTHER. AT
THE SHOW WITH INFORMATION. I
WAS DISTRACTED. BOB FROM THE
DATABASE PUBLICATIONS ARE NOT A
BUSINESS ON THE STORAGE. THE
BIG CHART BIG SORT OF SHOWS YOU
WERE BROUGHT WHAT ABOUT WHAT
ABOUT THREE. FOR MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND RECORDS STRAW IN
THIS PARTICULAR DATABASE. ORDER
THAT TO CAME OUT ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THESE
BATTERIES ARE BASED ON THE TIME
ABOUT TWO WEEKS. AND SOME OF
THEM ARE VERY BASIC FLOW
BATTERIES. REPORTER WORKING
LONG DURATION ENERGY STORAGE.
THE SERVER DINOSAUR. SO THAT
SHOWS YOU THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
THE LONGER SENTENCES TO THE
SPACE WHAT PROBABLY SHOWS
DEVELOPMENT. DEMONSTRATION AND
DEPLOYMENT OKAY IN CONSERVING
THE PREVIOUS SLIDE WHERE A
SHORTAGE MORE THAN TWO THIRDS
OF THOSE ISSUES REQUIRED WOULD
BE LOG DURATION THERE ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE BEST MORE.
OF OUR RESOURCES IN DEVELOPING
COST EFFECTIVE LONGER SENTENCES
STORAGE. SO ARE YOU SURE SURE
SOME TALKS WITH YOU. BASED ON
SOME OF MY OWN EXPERIENCES BOTH
WORKING AND PRIVATE SECTOR. I'M
SORRY AS A PROGRAM MANAGER IN.
OUR ADVANCED RESEARCH PROJECTS
AGENCY ENERGY IN. UP IN
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND THAT
SHORT FORMS ARE PRETTY. WHICH
IS AN AGENCY FARMS HIGH DECIDED
WHAT PRODUCTS ARE BRENT THERE
ARE A- AFTER WORKING AFTER
HAVING WHAT ELEVEN YEARS INTEL
THE SEMICONDUCTOR COMPANY EVENT
CORPORATE IS A PROGRAM DIRECTOR.
NUMBER TO START UP AND THEN
I'LL GET A LOT. BUT WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THAT I'VE SEEN.
WHICH I THINK I MIGHT.
PRINCIPAL PHOTOGRAPHY IS
GETTING INTO WHICH. FIRST OF
ALL WE EVER LOOKED AT MANY
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES READ THE
ORIGINAL PROCESS IS THE
SEMICONDUCTOR CHIP I WOULD
TECHNOLOGY OR- BECOME A BATTERY
OR ANY OTHER KIND OF STORAGE IF
FROM THE TIME YOU DISCOVERED OR
INVENTED NEW IDEA. THE TIME IT
IS SOLVE ALL MANUFACTURING'S
ISSUES YOU HAVE A SCALABLE
TECHNOLOGY EVERYBODY TO DEPLOY.
IT ROUGHLY TAKES FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY
DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH OF TIME
BECAUSE OF THE- REPORTER SO THE
CLIMATE CHANGE. IT WITHIN TEN
TO FIFTEEN YES SO WE JUST DON'T
HAVE SO WE NEED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT I'M SHIFT DRAMATICALLY
SCALING. NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
NEW IDEAS RIGHT PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW ENERGY AND ON TOP OF
THAT ENERGY IS ALSO CALLED
CONTRIBUTED BY THE FACT THAT
POLICY. AND INDIVIDUALS A
PRESERVATIVE IT'D BE BROKE.
RIGHT SO I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO DEVELOP REALLY GOOD PRIVATE
PUBLIC. PARTNERSHIP A FRAMEWORK
WHERE YOU CAN DRAMATICALLY
ACCELERATE. DISCOVERED A
MONSTER PLANET- TIME FRAME. AND
SOME OF THE OTHER. THAT WAS A
PARTICULARLY AS AS A GOVERNMENT
FUNDING AGENCY WHICH IS FUNDING
FOR THE STATE OR FEDERAL. A
REALLY GOOD IDEAS. ABOUT
PERSONAL TECHNOLOGY NEEDS WELL
AS YOU SHOULD DEFINE OBJECTIVES
NOT JUSTICE FOR THE VICTIMS.
LET THEY KNOW WE'RE JUST IT
OUT. AND THEM. YES SOME OF
THOSE IDEAS MAYES HAS BEEN
ARGUABLY THE BETTER ONES.
HOWEVER IN THE WATER NOT ONLY
THE BALL PARTY. ONLY THIS IS A
LOT OF. SO TO THE RESIDENCE.
SIMILARLY IT WAS- POLICY SHOULD
BE ACKNOWLEDGED INDIVIDUAL BUT
THE SHOULD PRODUCE VIDEO TACTIC
NOT ONLY GONZALEZ IS ON THE
IDEA THAT THE FUNDING. SEE WHAT
MAKES SENSE. RIGHT TO GET YOU
IN AS SOON AS I CAN WATER MORE
INFORMATION YOU WANTED
DEPLOYMENT OF DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS YEAH MORE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO MAKE THE COLLEGES
MEANT CALL. A COUPLE EXAMPLE
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE I WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE
I WAS FUNDING. OF IDEAS. WHEN I
WAS IN OURBODY I FUNDED IT HI
MY ONE OF MY PROGRAMS WAS ON.
DEVELOPING A LOW GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL- RESURGENCE RIGHT
SUFFERED A BUNCH OF PRODUCTS.
ALL THE PRODUCTS WHICH ARE
FUNDED FOR DEVELOPING GREEN
SOLUTION FOR BUILDINGS. IN THE
COURSE OF THE PROJECT I FOUND
OUT. TO RIDICULOUS TECHNOGYM
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS BECAUSE OF
THE THAT WE STARTED GETTING
FROM THE PROJECT. THAT THAT
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY MADE MORE
SENSE FOR THE REFRIGERATOR THAT
DOESN'T HAVE CONDITION. AT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM THE
DECISION I SAID OKAY LET'S JUST
FOCUS DON'T TRY TO FOCUS ON A
PRODUCT AND DINNER CONDITIONER
MAKE IT. WITH A REFRIGERATOR.
BUT I COULD MAKE THE DECISION
BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING THE
IDENTICAL ARE GONNA. AT THE
SAME TIME I'VE BEEN BACK OKAY
MANAGEMENT AND THE FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH THE- I CAN REMEMBER THEY
SAID THE GROUP. ALL RIGHT YOUR
IN THE DIRECTION OF THE PROJECT.
I'M NOT REALLY THAT DOES
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY. I
WOULD SAY A COUPLE- I DID A
REALLY GOOD PRODUCT AND A
SUCCESSFUL PROJECT. LAST NIGHT
I JUST WANT TO SHARE SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
ANY OF THIS KIND OF VISION THAT
I SHARED EVEN THOUGH THE SLIGHT.
IN OUR OWN LAB SO IN THE LAB
YOU HELP PEOPLE I MEAN WE ARE
MANY PEOPLE WORKING DIFFERENT
ENERGY STORAGE ALL OF IT FROM
HYDROGEN TO MEET THEM I AM TO
BECOME SELF ARE. COMING IN AS A
STORAGE. ASSEMBLY ALSO PEOPLE
WORKING WITH THE BALL THE-
POLICYMAKERS AND- DALLAS OR
ANOTHER ENTITY IS LOOKING A
DEPLOYMENT LOOKING AT POLICY
IMPACTS LOOKING AT. HOW TO
MONETIZE STORAGE. SO REALLY
LIKE TO BE NEED TO HARPER ONE
ORGANIZATION BUT ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
SHARE INFORMATION ON DOCTORS
OPPORTUNITY LEAD TO. HELP
ADVANCEMENT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IT HOPE TO SHRINK THE
TIMELINE FROM DISCOVERY'S LESS
INVENTION TO DEPLOYMENT. DO YOU
WANT TO THE DEPLOYMENT PEOPLE
ANALYSIS PEOPLE THE TECHNOLOGY
PEOPLE THE MATERIAL SCIENTISTS
EVERYBODY TO COME UNDER ONE
ENTITY SO THEY STARTED BUT YOU
NEVER KNOW THE SOURCE CENTER.
DR NOR BOCCE AND SHE RECENTLY
JOINED A LONG SIX MONTHS AGO AS
THE. UP THERE IN ORDER DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER. AND HERE WE ARE
LOOKING AT. AN OLD BRITISH KIND
OF THE- REGISTERED AS WELL IT
DOES NOT AND I AND ALSO WORKING
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND THE
PUBLIC. FUNDING AGENCIES
FINANCES AND I AM NOT BE ABLE
TO HAVE A BEAT ABOUT THE SUMMIT.
REGIS ARE JOINTLY ORGANIZED BY
TWO NATIONAL LABS HERE IN THE
BAY AREA AND BE INVITED. A LOT
ABOUT YOU KNOW THEY JUST STE IN
THAT AREA- IN THE SUMMIT AND
THEY HAVE TO SHARE A LOT OF. IT
TOO WAS NOTHING IN THIS FIELD
OF WHAT ELSE IS NEEDED. WE
WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
UNDERAGE SUMMIT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU A DOCTOR SO
JUST TO SUMMARIZE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS. WHAT ABOUT
REGISTERED FROM THE LAST
SPEAKER- DR BURGER THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED SOME SORT OF MASSIVE
STORAGE TECHNOLOGY AND- I'M
LOOKING BOTH. JUST TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA HOW BIG THIS IS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE AUDIENCE.
THEY TALK. OUR FIRST SPEAKER
TALKED ABOUT- HAVING FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS BROUGHT
ONLINE- AND THAT'S THREE HOURS
WORTH SO THAT'S FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEGAWATT HOURS. THE
KIND OF ESTIMATES WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM OUR LAST TWO SPEAKERS IS
WE'RE GONNA NEED NOT FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED. BUT TWO TO THREE AND A
HALF MILLION MEGAWATT HOURS OF
STORAGE IN THE FUTURE. SO GOING
FROM FORTY FIVE HUNDRED TO TWO
TO THREE AND A HALF MILLION.
CHEN IT'S- IT'S SORT OF
UNBELIEVABLE THAT WE CAN DO IT
AND AGAIN OUR LAST SPEAKER IS
SAYING WE HAVE TO DO IT BY
TWENTY THIRTY NOW- ONE THING
THAT YOU CAN DO WITH THE
NATIONAL LAB IS BRING EVERYONE
TOGETHER WE DID THAT AT
LAWRENCE LAB WHEN I WAS THERE
FOR. AT ESSENTIALLY TAKING
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE DEVELOPED
AND- SETTING UP- INCUBATORS
AND- THAT TRYING TO GET THAT
TECHNOLOGY OUT. AND MY QUESTION
FOR ALL THREE. OF THE FOLKS
HERE. IS- WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO.
TO ENCOURAGE THE INSTEAD OF
TAKING TWENTY FOUR YEARS OR
WHATEVER TO DEVELOP WE HAVE TO
DEVELOP IT IN TWO OR THREE
YEARS IN THE DEPLOYED ANOTHER
FIVE HOW THE HECK CAN WE DO
THAT AND WHAT CAN WE DO FROM A
POLICY POINT OF VIEW. A TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE. SO ALEX PERHAPS
YOU COULD GO FIRST. HI DOCTOR
KIRK THANK YOU YEAH YEAH I
THINK. SORRY IS IT OKAY IF I
CHAMPION YEAH YEAH ABSOLUTELY I
WANTED YOU TO JUMPED AND ALEX
OKAY YEAH WELL AGAIN I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING AT A VERY LARGE
PROBLEM AND I THINK FOR YOU ALL
IN THIS ROLE AN IMPORTANT ROLE
OF GOVERNMENT. IN AND HELPING
NAVIGATOR SET DIRECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA ON THESE ISSUES
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS WE
CAN DO AND LOOK AT. SOME OF
WHICH WERE ALREADY DOING WE'RE
ALREADY DOING I THINK A PRETTY
GOOD JOB OF INCUBATING EARLY
STAGE TECHNOLOGIES BUT THE
METAPHOR I USE IS IF YOU GO
BACK TO NINETEEN HUNDRED AND
YOU SAID HEY. PRETTY SOON WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GET ACROSS THE
ATLANTIC OCEAN WE WANT TO MOVE
REALLY QUICKLY- TELL ME WHICH
BOWED I SHOULD RESERVE AND AT
SOME POINT SOMEONE SAID WELL
DON'T RESERVE A BOAT BECAUSE
THERE'S THIS WHOLE NEW
TECHNOLOGY OF AIRPLANE AND I
CAN GET YOU OVER THERE FASTER.
AND SO THESE THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IF WE INCUBATE M.
AND WE SET UP. THE MATURATION
OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES FOR RIGHT
WHEN THE MARKET NEEDS THAT YOU
CAN REALLY SOLVE A LOT OF PAIN
AND REALLY HELP. AND I'D SAY
GIVEN THE URGENCY. OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE KNOW. THE CLOCK IS
TICKING AND WE KNOW WE NEED
THIS SUITE OF TECHNOLOGIES
THERE I THINK STUDY AFTER STUDY
SHOWING THAT. AND SO REALLY THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE READY
THAT TOOL KIT AND WHAT CAN WE
DO. AND SPECIFICALLY THERE'S-
PROGRAMS CAN HELP. FUNDING CAN
HELP FOR INSTANCE THE BUDGET IS
LOOKING AT FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
FOR CVC PROGRAMS FOR LONG
DURATION. AND YEAH THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT THING AND IN
IN MY INDUSTRY. CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS THERE HAVE PROMPTED I
WOULD SAY THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
CONVERSATION. IN RENEWED
INTEREST IN CALIFORNIA PLANTS
MANUFACTURING EXPLORATION SO
ALL OF THIS STUFF HAPPENS. WHEN
YOU GUYS TALK ABOUT IT. AND THE
WORLD IS PAYING ATTENTION I
THINK WE ALSO NEED POLICY
DIRECTIONS ON ADDING DIVERSITY
TO THE FLEET IN THE RIGHT WAYS.
AND WE NEED POLICY EFFORTS TO
DIVERSIFY THE FLEET MAYBE AND
DIRECTED WAYS- WE HAVE A REALLY
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
THAT SHOULD BE PART OF THE-
TOOL KIT. BUT THEY NEED. HELP
COVERING THAT GREEN PREMIUM AND
ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO THAT IS
WHAT WE CALL BY DOWN FUNDS
WHERE- FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO
OFFSET THAT GREEN PREMIUM JUST
SO WE HAVE THAT EXTRA TOOL IN
THE TOOL KIT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
AND SO WE'RE SUPPORT ABOUT ALL
OF THAT- AND I CAN COME UP WITH
MORE SOME MORE SPECIFIC-
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT I WANTED TO JUST
START WITH THAT LIST- THAT'S
EXCELLENT WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST TO BUY DOWN THE PRICE.
IS TO TELL PG&E AND EDISON AND
OTHER LARGE UTILITIES- PURCHASE
GREEN ENERGY. NOW THE BUY DOWN
COST WHERE WERE WE WERE PAYING
FOR SOLAR FARM MORE THAN TEN WE
WOULD FOR NATURAL GAS PLANT AND
NOT GETTING THE FLEXIBILITY OF%
NATURAL GAS PLANT THAT COST WAS
DEAD BY THE RATE PAYERS. THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON WHY WE NOW
HAVE SUCH HIGH ENERGY PRICES
AND A MATTER OF FACT THE- THE
CCC ARE. OUR COMMUNITY- ENERGY
COMPANIES WE'VE GOT NOW REALLY
COMPLAIN MORE WE HAVE TO HAVE
ALL OF THESE OLD COSTS WHY
CAN'T WE JUST HAVE THE NEW
SOLAR PANEL. BECAUSE WE ALL
INVESTED IN THE OLD SOLAR AND
WE ALL GOT TO CONTINUE TO PAY
FOR IT BUT- AT SOME POINT THAT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT TO SAY
THE RATE PAYERS ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR IT ALSO THAT'S JUST ONE
QUESTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE- CAN WE HAVE- DO WE HAVE
SINCE. YEAH IT SUCKS BONTA. I'M
SORRY MR FOR RESPOND REALLY
QUICKLY-YEAH MISTER MARCUS IS
ALEX GET AROUND ALSO WE HAVE
SOME UNIQUE FEDERAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES IF WE POSITION
OURSELVES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT MONEY AND THAT'S A VERY
LIVE DEBATE I KNOW THE CECE'S
WELL POSITION ON THAT. IN HIS
INDUSTRY AND DOES- CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY LEADERSHIP AND
LEGISLATURE WE CAN ALL GEAR UP
AND STRATEGIZE TO DO THAT- INTO
IT REALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL SUPPORT SO THAT IT
DOESN'T FALL AS MUCH ON
CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS. THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
PEOPLE SOMETIMES SAY WE ARE
ONLY RESPONSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA.
5% OF THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
WHAT ARE WHAT WE HEARD TODAY.
IS YEAH WE'RE RESPONSIBLE 41%
WE GOTTA DO OUR FAIR SHARE
GETTING THAT DOWN BUT- WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS YOU'RE
DEVELOPING THE TECHNOLOGIES FOR
THE WHOLE COUNTRY. AND THAT'S
IN FACT THE PLAN THAT WE
DEVELOP THOSE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE SHOW BY EXAMPLE. THAT'S ALSO
THE REASON WHY WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO HAVE ANY BROWNOUTS OR
BLACKOUTS. MEMBER BENNETT I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AM I ON YES
YOU NEED TO PRESS. HELLO THERE
NOW ON MY OWN YES GOOD GOOD
THANK YOU OF UP THREE QUICK
HINGS NUMBER ONE YOUR NUMBER
OF TWO MILLION TO THREE MILLION
STORAGE- I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND MORE HOW YOU GOT TO
THAT WELLNESS. AT WE CHEN A
HUNDRED HOURS OF STORAGE THIS
WAS FROM- DOCTOR BERGER FROM
FOR MANAGING A SAID WE NEED A
HUNDRED HOURS. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED HOURS
FOR ROUGHLY TWENTY THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. AND IF YOU MULTIPLY
A HUNDRED TIMES TWENTY THOUSAND
YOU GET TWO MILLION SO TWO
MILLION MEGAWATT HOURS.
COMPARED TO WHAT WE DID LAST
YEAR WHICH IS FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED MAKE A LOT HOURS SO
THANK YOU. JUST YOU GO FROM
FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TWO
TWO MILLION OR THREE MILLION OR
THREE MILLION AND A HALF IT.
WILL RAISE WE'RE WE'RE DOING
SOME ARM WAVING HERE IS
SUPPOSED TO HAND WAVING BUT THE
NUMBERS ARE JUST YOU AND- LLOYD
IS JUST GONNA TAKE A LONG TIME
IF IT TAKES LONGER THAN WE HAVE
SO WE'D BETTER. START NOW. MUST
BE DEBT BY OTHER TWO QUESTIONS-
AND ALEX APPRECIATE DID YOU
GIVING US YOUR INSIGHT IS JUST.
JUST A GENERAL INSIGHT ON ON
TWO THINGS AND THAT IS. ON BY
DOWN PROGRAMS FOR THE GREEN
PREMIUM. IS IT BETTER FOR. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO.
COMPLETELY FUND- A PARTICULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM- THE-
INSTALLATION OF ELECTRIC
CHARGING STATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
OR IS IT BETTER FOR- THE STATE
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE AND
INSTEAD OF SAYING IF YOU PUT IN
ELECTRIC CHARGING STATION WILL
WILL PROVIDE. 30% OF THE COST
OR 40% OF THE COST. TO TRY TO
BUY DOWN THE GREEN PREMIUM FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHICH ONE IS
GOING TO GET US THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED.
THE FASTEST THE BEST OF THE
BEST INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
NEED IT THE QUICKEST CENTER.
YEAH GOOD QUESTION MISTER
BENNETT ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO SPEAK
YEAH I HAVE A VERY. WIDE
MEMBERSHIP AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE STRONG OPINIONS ON THE
BEST WAY FOR THEM TO HELP- AND
I DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT ANSWER
FOR YOU IN TERMS OF ITS THIS
WAY OR THAT WAY BUT I DO WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT. THESE ARE ALL
COMPANIES WILLING TO PUT OUT.
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS- THEY'RE INVESTING A
LOT OF MONEY AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT THE REALITY IS. THEY
DO THAT AS PART OF THE BUSINESS
SO THEY NEED TO HAVE SOME
VISIBILITY TO. WHAT THE RETURNS
AND RISK CAR AND THAT'S ONE
THING WE CAN REALLY CONTROL SO
IF WE DO TAKE THE PATH OF AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. I THINK IT'S
EASY FOR THEM TO SEE- THAT
RETURN PEACE AND THAT REDUCES
UNCERTAINTY ALTERNATIVELY IF
THE STATE WANTS TO ENTER LONG
TERM CONTRACTS THAT'S ANOTHER
WAY OF REDUCING RISK ON. ON
THESE COMPANIES AND HELPING
THEM GET CHEAPER FINANCING TO
MAKE THE PROJECT PENCIL OUT.
AND OTHER THAN THAT MAYBE YOU
KNOW FORM WOULD HAVE A
PARTICULAR OPINION OF WHAT
WORKS BEST BECAUSE I WHAT I SEE
IS. A LOT OF COMPANIES HAVE
DIFFERENT RISK APPETITES. AND
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO IT AND
AGAIN MY- MY SENSE OF IT- AS A
GREAT EXPERT AND NOT JUST AS
THE- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF C.
SAYS THAT. THE NEEDS ARE HUGE
JUST CHECK CANTIK AND SO I'M
I'M INTERESTED IN A BIT OF A
SHOCK IN APPROACH FRANKLY.
BECAUSE WE REALLY ARE FACING A
LEVEL OF STORAGE DEPLOYMENTS
THAT'S NEVER BEEN ACHIEVED
EVER. YOU KNOW THOUSANDS OF
MEGAWATTS MEGAWATTS PER YEAR
IT'S NEVER BEEN DONE. AND SO
OPERATE JUST ABOUT THE
EXECUTION PIECE FRANKLY.
AMONGST MY SECOND QUESTION- IF
I COULD NOT SPEAK. ENGLISH
PLEASE- AND THAT IS THAT. YOU
KNOW OF DR KIRCH SHOWED US.
YEAH AND I KNOW IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO BE ON DURING THAT PART
OF THE PRESENTATION BUT SHOWED
US- THERE IS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT VALUE IN AND HAVING
SOLAR. HAVING SOLAR CAPACITY-
OR A COMBINATION OF SOLAR AND
WIND CAPACITY TO TAKE CARE OF A
100% OF OUR WINNER NEEDS. AND
THEN THAT WOULD BE FAR MORE
THAN WE NEED IN THE SUMMERTIME
BUT THEN WE COULD USE THAT
SUMMER TIME- SOLAR AND WIND
CAPACITY TO GENERATE LOW COST-
HYDROGEN. AND THE OTHER TECH
ALLERGIES THAT- SHE DESCRIBED
THAT WE COULD USE WITH THAT. SO
TO WHAT EXTENT DO YOU THINK
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE- IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE FOR US TO GO AHEAD
AND JUST. KEEP PUSHING ON THE
SOLAR SIDE SO THAT WE LOWER THE
COST OF THE SOLAR. ELECTRICITY
WE HAVE PLENTY OF IT AND WE
HAVE. A LITTLE FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD QUOTE INEXPENSIVE
ELECTRICITY THAT IS AVAILABLE.
FOR THE STORAGE OPTIONS THAT
ARE OUT THERE WHETHER IT'S
HYDROGEN OF THE OTHER OPTIONS.
COULD CAN YOU GIVE ME YOUR SORT
OF INITIAL REACTION TO THAT-
THOUGHT. ABSOLUTELY YEAH GREAT
QUESTION IN MY SENSE OF IT IS-
THAT. WE NEED A BETTER BALANCE
BETWEEN THE SOLAR GENERATION
AND STORAGE COMING ONLINE AND
AS WE PUSH THE STORAGE FURTHER
WE PUSH THE SOLAR FURTHER YOU
NEED LONGER DURATION STORAGE.
SO YOU REALLY WANT TO BE
INCREMENTING FORWARD ON BOTH
FRONTS AND- YEAH AS AS GAVE
MENTIONED WE SEE RIGHT NOW HOW
IF WE PUSH TOO HARD ON THE
SOLAR. IT THEN IT'S HARD FOR
THE GREAT TO OPERATE WITHOUT
ENOUGH STORAGE EVEN NOW EVEN
THIS SUMMER AND LAST SUMMER AND
SO. I THINK AS WE PUSH LIKE YOU
SUGGEST WE SHOULD ON THE
SMALLER SIDE BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THE STORAGE IS
KEEPING UP. AND THAT IT'S
ADDING TO ITS DURATION ACROSS
TIME SO THAT IT CAN HELP SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS I GUESS AND
THERE'S ONE OTHER QUICK NOTE
REALLY SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU
SIR- BUT I YOU KNOW THERE'S SO
MANY THINGS WE CAN DO WITH
EXTRASOLAR IT'S A GREAT
PROBLEM. AND ON ONE HAND- WE
KNOW THAT CURTAILING SOLDIERS
REALLY INEXPENSIVE QUICK
SOLUTION. BUT THERE'S ALSO WAYS
WE CAN USE SOLAR ENERGY WE CAN
CREATE HEAT THAT THEN IS USED
FOR DRYING PRUNES AND WHICH IS
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS
RIGHT SO YOU THERE YOU CAN
DRIVE ALL THESE INDUSTRIES.
JUST WITH A LOT OF EXTRA CHEAP
POWER IN CALIFORNIA I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO GET TO
AND THAT IS THAT. IT IT
CERTAINLY THERE NEED TO BE A
BALANCE BUT YOU COULD HAVE
EXCESS SOLAR AND IT'S NOT TOO
EXPENSIVE TO TURN IT OFF. IF
YOU INCENTIVISED IT PROPERLY IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING HEY THIS
IS. NOT STROLLER THIS GONNA
NECESSARILYBE PURCHASED BY THE
POWER COMPANIES RIGHT NOW
EXCEPT FOR- BUT- WHAT YOU'RE
PUTTING IN A PROJECT TO. EITHER
SCALE THAT PROJECT LARGER THAN
YOU THOUGHT BECAUSE OF THIS OR
IF WE INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
SCALE IT LARGER THAN YOU
THOUGHT. BECAUSE FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW THE STORAGE IS GOING
TO CATCH UP- AND NOW YOU'VE
YEAH IT'S EASIER TO HAVE THE
STORAGE CATCH UP IF YOU KNOW
FOR SURE YOU'VE GOT THE ABILITY
TO CREATE. EITHER LOW COST
HYDROGEN OR LOW COST OTHERS
OTHER STORAGE OPTIONS I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I'M- REFERRING TO
SO I. I'M JUST I'M REALLY
TRYING TO CHALLENGE THE
QUESTION THE ISSUE OF WHETHER.
WE SHOULD NOT DO SOLAR UNTIL WE
HAVE THE STORAGE OR WHETHER WE-
YOU KNOW CAN DO THAT CAN MAKE
ALMOST KIND OF LEAPFROG- AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD TO SOME
EXTENT. ANY FINAL YEAH I. YEAH
THIS LONG TO BRING IN A STORAGE
CAN MOVE AGREE. ON SOLAR SO.
BECAUSE YOU CAN ALWAYS CURTAIL
AND- I THINK THE INCREMENTAL
COST OF NEW SOLAR SHOWING TO BE
QUITE INEXPENSIVE SO IT'S A
IT'S NOT A- CHANGE YOUR
STRATEGY AND IN TERMS OF GRID
RELIABILITY BUT SHE JUST NEED
TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE
STORIES COMING ALONG OR ELSE
YOU'RE REQUIRED. TO RELY ON THE
OLDER UNITS YOU HAVE THESE
DIFFERENT MANAGING ISSUES AND
IF YOU ACTUALLY JUST KEEP THE
OLDER UNITS ON UNTIL YOU GET
THE RIGHT COMBINATION OF
STORAGE ON. HAND AND SOLAR SO
YOU KEEP IT IS THAT JUST AS A
TERMINATION OF WHEN YOU SHUT
THE OLDER UNITS OFFICE WHEN YOU
HAVE THE PROPER AMOUNT OF
STORAGE DEGREE YEAH AND I CALL
THAT FRANKLY TURNOVER IT'S VERY
NORMAL PROBLEM AND WE SHOULD
JUST APPROACH IT AND I THINK.
THE LANGUAGE YOU GUYS ARE
DEVELOPING TODAY IS ALSO
HELPING EVERYONE YOU KNOW- NO
DISCHARGED OR WHAT I CALL LONG
HOLD STORAGE. IS A PROBLEM WE
NEED AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU
ASSOCIATE WITH SEASONAL STORAGE
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN- THE
DAILY DISCHARGE STORAGE BECAUSE
YOU MAY HAVE. A STORAGE THAT IS.
HOUSE SELF DEPLETING
CHARACTERISTICS BUT IF YOU'RE
USING IT EVERYDAY IT'S FUN AND
SO AS LONG AS WE CAN IN THIS
LANGUAGE AND CLARIFY FOR
INDUSTRY WHAT PROBLEMS TO
SOLVE. IN MY EXPERIENCE IS
THEY'RE THEY'RE WILLING TO SHOW
UP FOR CALIFORNIA AND- PLACING
BETS IN A GOOD WAY FOR US THANK
YOU OUR- MEMBER BENEFITS. I
JUST REALLY QUICKLY I HAVE
SHOWN THAT IN. JANUARY SO IF
YOU BUILD OUT SOLAR YOU'LL HAVE
ENOUGH TO MEET THE LOAD HOWEVER
THAT'S A MONTHLY NUMBER. YOU
STILL HAVE TO QUIT SO HE COULD
WITHOUT MUCH SOLAR AND YOU
STILL NEED MORE STORAGE TO GET
THROUGH THE NIGHT AND TO GET
THROUGH A CLOUDY WEEK. AND IT'S
JUST THAT YOU DON'T NEED AS
MUCH SEASONAL BUT YOU ACTUALLY
WHEN YOU DO THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO ASK- ALEX WAS JUST SAYING.
EVERY TIME YOU ADD MORE SOLAR
YOU NEED TO USE TO ADD A
COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF STORAGE
TO BE ABLE TO USE THE DAY TIME
TO GET THROUGH THE NIGHT.
EXCELLENT AND BY THE WAY- I HAD
ONE NUMBER THAT THREE AND A
HALF MILLION MEGAWATT HOURS
THAT CAME FROM DOCTOR KURDS. 1%
OF ROUGHLY FORTY MEGAWATTS- IS
SORT OF THE KIND OF AVERAGE
NUMBER FOR ELECTRICITY
GENERATION CALIFORNIA MAYBE
IT'S TWENTY OR SIXTY BUT IF.
THAT'S IN THE BALLPARK. TIMES
THREE SIXTY FIVE TIMES TWENTY
FOUR AND YOU GET THREE AND A
HALF MILLION MEGAWATT HOURS. SO
THESE ARE JUST BALLPARK NUMBERS
BUT- THE POINT IS YOU'RE
COMPARING A MILLION. TWO FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED. THAT'S
THE KIND OF LEAP THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE AND VERY QUICKLY IF
WE'RE TO BELIEVE DOCTOR BERGER
WHICH I DO THAT THIS HAS TO
HAPPEN BY TWENTY THIRTY. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
THIS PLEASE ONE OF THE SO. LOOK
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE WHOLE
COMPLETE STORY YET SO THAT'S
ANOTHER THING. THE SEATTLE ALSO
NOT AVAILABLE IN THE HOME.
OVERPRODUCTION BUT YOU WANT ONE
FACTORIES WILL GIVE US SIX
HOURS RIGHT. WITH THE FACTORY
THE ECONOMICAL ECONOMIC OUTPUT
OF A FACTOR DEPENDS ON WHETHER
IT'S AND I NEED TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF OCT. REACH SO WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN YOU WILL DISCOVER
FACT IS IMPLEMENTED IN START
BURNING NATURAL GAS IN THE
EVENING THE END PRODUCT. SO
THAT'S BECAUSE HARD LOOK AT ONE
ASPECT OF THE ENERGY ECONOMY
AND DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE REST
OF THE STUFF PEOPLE BELIEVES.
THAT ENERGY. SO THAT IS
SOMETHING TO REALLY KEEP IN
MIND AND THAT'S- THE SECOND ONE
IS I WAS GOING TO SAY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO PRODUCE A
LOT OF HYDROGEN. RIGHT NOW HE
CANNOT. 100% HYDROGEN IN THIS
DEBATE LINE IS NOT POSSIBLE
THAT A LOT OF TECHNICAL RISK.
WHICH IS WHICH IS A LONG. SO
AND THE PEOPLE ARE TALKED
ABOUT. WE'RE GOING 2% OF THOSE
IN THE MIX WITH NATURAL GAS
THAT DOESN'T GET YOU TO A
REPRESENTATIVE WILL. EIGHT SO I
GOT THAT WILL ALSO DECIDE HOW
YOU WANT TO PRODUCE AN URGENT
SHOULD BE BORN OKAY DODD WAS A
PRODUCTION VOWED THAT USES
GOING TO BE. SO DO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DOUBLE UP NEW
PIPELINES. WHICH CAN PROTRUSION.
SO THESE ARE THE KIND OF
CONVERSATION THAT WE EVER HAVE
BEFORE DECIDING ON. WHICH
STRATEGY MAKES SENSE UN
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE SEEN THAT.
THERE TENDENCIES TO FOCUS ON
ONE PART OF THE PROBLEM. I
THINK THAT SOMEBODY HAS MATURED
ON THE SPOT WEST OF THE PARK.
AND AGAIN WITH THE TAGLINE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS. WE NEED TO START
LOOKING AT EACH US BACKED OFF.
THE PROBLEM ALL THE WAY FROM
PRODUCTION TO DELIVERY TO USE.
AND WHAT OTHER THINGS
DOWNSTREAM EVEN OTHER TALENTED
THAT NEEDS TO BE SOLVED. THE
STRUCTURES AS BIGOTRY AGAINST.
AND MISTER PARK MAY I JUST
SPEAK WITHOUT HIGH POINT. YEAH
THAT YOU KNOW AND SEE SO WE ARE
TECHNICAL SO WE LIKE ALL
STORAGE- WELL YOU'RE A BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE STORAGE OR SMALL
BATTERIES. AND HYDROGEN IS PART
OF THE STORAGE TOOL KIT FROM
OUR STANDPOINT HYDROGEN ALSO
HAS SIMILAR BENEFITS YOU KNOW
IT CAN APPLY TO INDUSTRY AND
TRANSPORTATION APPLICATIONS. I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ALLEY W. HE'S DOING REALLY
GREAT WORK AND E'RE AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF. A UTILITY THINKING
AHEAD STICKING ITS NECK OUT AND
I DO THINK WE SHOULD REALLY
LOOK AT IT MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR- HYDROGEN EXPLORATION
PROJECTS ARE SUCCESSFUL AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THEY'RE DOING IS
CALLED HIGH DEAL. WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER TALK JUST LIKE DOCTOR
CRUSHER MACHINE IT SAYING AND
THEY'RE HAMMERING THIS OUT WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WHEN WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO ON YOUR SIDE SO
THAT I CAN MAKE MY SITE WORK.
AND GETTING ALL THAT TOGETHER
IS THE TYPE OF COORDINATED
TACTICAL APPROACH I THINK MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE. AND I THINK
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT
LOOKING AT HOW DWP IS
CONVERTING ITS- FORMALLY CALL
UNIT IN UTAH INTO- HYDROGEN
STORAGE- SYSTEM IS SOMETHING
THAT. CERTAINLY WE WOULD WANT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS OF
MOVING THE NEEDLE FORWARD FOR
THE STATE. AND YEAH I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT POLICY NEEDS
THERE ARE TO FACILITATE THAT
BUT I DO THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ONE THAT WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT FOR. YOU SUPPORTING
IT MAKING SURE IT'S SUCCESSFUL
OUTSIDER. YES ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF. THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
WHERE WE'RE GETTING DOWN TO
SOME PILOT INVESTMENT. BOY WE
HAVE TO DEPLOY SO QUICKLY. IT'S
SCARY. I'M MEMBER BENNETT I
THINK THAT YOUR- QUESTIONS WERE
QUITE HELPFUL AND I BELIEVE THE
GENERAL AUDIENCE- IN THE WAY
YOU SUMMARIZE THINGS WILL FIND
THE WAY YOU UNDERSTAND THAT TO
BE VERY HELPFUL TO THEM AS WELL
SO THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS- NUMBER CALDERON DO
YOU. WANT TO ADD ANYTHING. I
NEVER GOING TO ASK YEAH HI. YES
AND I THINK WAS VERY IMPORTANT-
DOCTOR BERGER DID YOU WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING MORE. I THINK
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN COVERED
REALLY WELL HERE I JUST WENT
OUT AND OF REEMPHASIZE SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT ALEX MADE- THAT
IN A REALLY LONG TERM SIGNALS
THAT REALLY KIND OF ORIENTING
THE MARKET TO ASK THINK ABOUT
KIND OF WHERE WE NEED TO HAD
AND HOW DO WE PRIORITIZE.
BUILDING TOWARDS THAT IS REALLY
CRITICAL- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
NUMBER OF POLICY MECHANISMS AS
IS ALEX MENTIONED- THAT CAN GET
US THERE AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
DESIGNING THOSE IN A TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AWAY THAT REALLY ARE
FOCUSED AROUND THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT SO WE WE'VE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THIS PROBLEM OF
NEEDING TO- KIND OF POWER OUR
GRADES THROUGH THESE MULTI DAY-
PARTICULARLY WINTER ADD IT YOU
KNOW OCCURRING LOW RENEWABLE
ENERGY EVENTS SO NOW THAT WE'VE
KIND OF DEFINED THAT PROBLEM
AND PERHAPS WE CAN REALLY WORK
TO FIND THAT PROBLEM EVEN
FURTHER WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASKS OVER THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. NO ANSWER TO FIND A
PROBLEM HOW WE DEFINE PROGRAMS
THAT THEN ORIENT THE MARKET
TOWARDS SOLVING THAT PROBLEM
AND THE KIND OF ALLOWING THESE-
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS TO SCALE
AND YOU KNOW REALLY CREEPY
INVESTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE
AND REALLY ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES. OTHER NECESSARY IN
ADVANCE OF THAT SCALING- AND DO
THAT AND KIND OF OUR A REALLY-
A WAY THAT ALLOWS US TO MANAGE
RISK EFFECTIVELY SO I THINK
THAT'S IT THAT'S- REALLY WHAT
WE LIKE TO FOCUS ON YOUR- ARM
AT THE END OF THIS I WILL TRY
AND PUT TOGETHER A ONE TO TWO
PAGE SUMMARY OF. WHAT WE
LEARNED AND SO I'LL BE GETTING
BACK TO THE U. S. SPEAKERS-
PARTICULARLY- DOCTOR BERGER
YOUR PROJECTION AS TO WHAT WE
NEEDED TWENTY THIRTY. I. THINK
THAT WAS AN EXTREMELY- IMPORT-
ASSESSMENT A ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT IDEAS TO COME OUT OF
THIS IS JUST HOW MUCH WE NEED
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A MILLION OR SO
MAKE FOR HAPPY HOURS. JUST
ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE. AND THEN
WE SHOULD FACE THAT NOW. I'M
GOING TO GET TO THE NEXT PANEL
AND THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH IF
YOU WANT TO STAY AROUND WE'RE
GOING TO BE TALKING NOW ABOUT
WHAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS
DOING. AND WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING ONE MORE
QUESTION THAT QUESTION I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AT- A
FEW MINUTES BEFORE FOR I WILL
HAVE TO LEAVE I'M SURE SO IF
THE PANELS GOING ON AT YOUR
WILL WILL TRY AND FINISH THAT
PANEL AT FOUR O'CLOCK AND THEN
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH
FOUR THIRTY. OKAY SO- THAT
MEANS- FOR THE NEXT TWO
SPEAKERS. ONE FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE OTHER FROM
SANDIA NATIONAL LAB- TO TALK
ABOUT. THE NATIONAL EFFORTS
AND- THE EARTH SHOT AS THEY'RE
CALLING IT. SO FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM. MISTER
MIKE- GRAVELLY- PROGRAM
RESEARCH RESEARCH PROGRAM
MANAGER THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION- HE'S THE TEAM LEAD
IN SEEN OUR SENIOR ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER FOR THE ENERGY SYSTEMS
RESEARCH OFFER. OFFICE AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
HIS TEAM IS MANAGING OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN.
MICROGRID ENERGY STORAGE AND
RELATED ENERGY RESEARCH AND
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS- SO NOT
A MONEY BONTA RESEARCH- MR
GRAVELLY- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN KIRK AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
JUST FOR BACKGROUND ON MYSELF I
HAVE THAT'S IN YOUR COMMISSION
NINETEEN YEARS. I WORK IN YOUR
STORE YOU ENTER TIME CARD IN
THERE I WORKING YOUR STORAGE
AND DISPOSAL GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE INDUSTRY- I ALSO WANTED
FOR BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T TALKED
MUCH ABOUT TODAY IF YOU KNOW
THE REALLY A TRUE MOST
PREDOMINANT LONG DURATION
STORAGE WE HEARD A FEW OTHER
ONES ARE IN FACT PUMPED HYDRO
AND HYDROGEN. AND IN MOST CASES
OF PUMPED HYDRO YOU KNOW
REPRESENTS OVER 90% OF THE LONG
DURATION STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE NATION AND THE WORLD AND
MOST SENATE REPRESENTATIVES
TODAY CONCERT A PUMPED HYDRO TO
BE MATURE COMMERCIAL AND ENABLE
TO PROVIDE LONG DURATION AND
SEASONAL STORAGE. INSURANCE DOT
COM TIGER WAS PASSED EARLIER IN
THE COST OF PUMPED HYDRO
PROJECTS IN THE FUTURE CAN
CHANGE REALLY BE WELL
DOCUMENTED TO- PROJECTS OF
PLANES AND COSTS ARE PRETTY
WELL KNOWN. AND PERFORMANCE IS
PRETTY WELL EXPECT. HI IS A
LITTLE. CAL ARE PROPER FOCUS ON
HOW. IS CARBON. RENEWABLE I.
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
AVAILABLE FOSSIL FUEL BASED
CREATE HYDROGEN AND BLOW
HUNDRED YOUR- NOBLE GREEN
HYDROGEN STILL VIEWED BY MOST
OF THE ALL THE INDUSTRY AS AN
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY WHEN
CONSIDERING IT FOR LONG
DURATION STORAGE ARE FOR-
INTEREST A LONG- ARPA SEASONAL
STORAGE. THANK YOU COMMISSION
HAS INVESTED AND WILL CONTINUE
TO INVEST MORE IN THE COMING
YEARS TO GRADUATE DEMONSTRATE
USE. OF RENEWABLE GREEN
HYDROGEN AS A FUTURE ENERGY
STORAGE RESOURCE- ALSO NEED.
NINETEEN THOUSAND TWENTY THEIR
DISCRETION COMPLETED SURE
RESEARCH OVER THE FULL SPECTRUM
OF HYDROGEN USES. AND LOOK AT
THE DECARBONISATION OF HOWHARD
IT CAN BE USED IN THINGS LIKE
THE DECARBONISATION OF THE
INDUSTRY AND- AND AGRICULTURAL
VERY HARD. TO DECARBONISE
INDUSTRIES- ALSO TO LOOK.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE EXCESS-
EXPECTED FROM HIGH RENEWABLE
PENETRATION OR OF A BUILD UP IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING IF WE IF
CALIFORNIA REALIZES ITS
OFFSHORE WIND CAPACITY.
ADDITIONALLY JUST FOR
INFORMATION FOR YOU TO FINISH
YOUR MISSION WILL RELEASE A
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATION LATER
THIS YEAR. TO DEVELOP A GREEN
HYDROGEN ROADMAP AND MASTER
PLAN. THAT WILL ADDRESS ALL
THESE OPPORTUNITIES TO IDENTIFY
WHICH ONES HAVE THE MOST
POTENTIAL TO SUPPORT. THE GOALS
OF SB ONE HUNDRED. THANK YOU
COMMISSION HAVE SEVERAL OUR
RESEARCH PROGRAM FUNDING
SOURCES BY AND BY FAR THE
LARGEST IS THE ELECTRIC PROGRAM
INVESTMENT CHARGE YOU PRO BOWL
BUT ABOUT THAT HERE TODAY. YEP
PROBLEM IS CREATED BY THE
PUBLIC CHILL COMMISSION AND IS
YOUR MINISTER ABOUT ENTRY
COMMISSION AND THE THREE ARE
YOU. DIFFERENT PROGRAMS NOW
THIS CHANCE HERE ON THE PROGRAM
HAS INVESTED IN NURTURING YOUR
STORES THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
DECADE. THERE ARE YEARS FOR
FOCUS ON ENCOURAGING A WIDE
RANGE OF NEW AND EMERGING
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES TO
DEMONSTRATE THE CAPABILITY ON
THEIR VALUE TO THE MARKETPLACE.
THE RESULTING TECHNOLOGIES FROM
THIS TIME FRAMEWORK SHORT
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE FOUR
HOURS OR LESS BECAUSE THE
OVERALL MARKET HAS NOT
RECOGNIZED THE NEED FOR LONG
DURATION MONITOR STORAGE
CAPABILITIES. SEVERAL OF THE
COMPANIES RECEIVED OVERSEEING
ETHNIC FUNDING WERE ABLE TO
ADVANCE OUR TECHNOLOGY WHICH
REPORT THAT THEY RECEIVED
INTERNATIONAL ORDERS. THEN
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO THE
COMMISSION SHADED RESEARCH INTO
LONG DURATION STORAGE AS IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT SOLUTIONS
WERE NEEDED FOR A LONGER
DURATION BOTH TO MITIGATE
AGAINST FIRE EMPIRE SHUTTLES.
INTO ADDRESS PERIODS WHEN
RENEWABLE MIGHT HAVE REDUCED
CAPACITY FOR LONG HOURS AT A
TIME. SEVERAL PROMISING
TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS FLOW
BATTERIES FLYWHEELS IN ADVANCED
CHEMISTRY BATTERIES OR MERGE
DURING THIS TIME FRAME. THAT
WERE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF LONG DURATION IN
YOUR STORES THE COULD PROVIDE
EIGHT HOURS MORE CAPACITY. AS A
RESULT OF THIS RESEARCH ENERGY
COMMISSION DEVELOPED A NEW
LONGER RATIONING YOUR STORAGE
COMPETITIVENESS PROTECTION. BUT
WAS RELEASED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. ALSO DURING THIS TIME
FRAME DANGER COMMISSION BEGAN
TO RESEARCH A SEASONAL ENERGY
STORAGE. I LIKE THE HIGHLIGHTS
KEY IN. THE POLICY EARLY
RESEARCH IN TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WOULD YOU COMMISSION AWARDED
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN SEPARATE FUNDS AND MATCH
FUNDS. TO TWENTY FIVE ENERGY
STORAGE GRANTS TO DEVELOP AND
DEMONSTRATE THE FULL SPECTRUM
OF IN YOUR STORAGE CAPABILITY
SHORT DURATION OF LONG DURATION
AND SEASONAL. I DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE WORD FOR ACRE. TO CHECK
OVER OF INNOVATIVE ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD
PROVIDE TEN HOURS OR MORE. OF
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS IN THE
FIELD APPLICATIONS. THREE
GRANTS TO BUILD AND DEMONSTRATE
THE NEWEST REPORT TYPE SYSTEM
AGAIN PROVIDING YOUR STORAGE
FOR UP TO ONE HUNDRED HOURS.
THREE GRANTS TO ASSESS THE
FUTURE. SOLUTION INTEGRATES
SEVERAL I DON'T WANT THE FULL
SPECTRUM OF LONG DURATION
STORAGE. AND ELIMINATE THEM THE
LEVEL OF LONG DURATION STORAGE
CAPABILITY THAT WILL BE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE
STATE UNDER SB ONE HUNDRED. ONE
OF THOSE EIGHT CONVERGING LONG
DURATION STORAGE TECHNOLOGY
ISSUES BASED ON AWKWARD
PROPOSED TITLE TECHNOLOGY IN
WILL DEMONSTRATE SEASONAL
ENERGY STORAGE HOWEVER VERY
SMALL SCALE. IN ADDITION TO THE
LABORATORY RESEARCH AN INFILL
DEMONSTRATIONS EPIC PROGRAM
ALSO PROVIDES GRANTS TO
EMERGING STORAGE COMPANIES TO
EXPAND THEIR MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITY IN CALIFORNIA.
OVERCOME BARRIERS AND
LIMITATIONS ON THE MARKET PLACE
AND TO HELP THEM DEVELOP
BUSINESS PLANS SO THEY CAN
ATTRACT HIGHER LEVELS OF THIRD
PARTY INVESTMENT. WHEN LOOKING
AT THE DESIRED DISCUSSION TOPIC
FOR THE WORKSHOP TODAY THAT
WE'VE HAD THROUGHOUT THE DAY
THE COMMISSION IS ACTING
ACTIVELY WORKING. OF THE STATE
TO INSURE OF THE FULL SCALE
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES NEEDED TO
MEET FUTURE GOALS OF THE STATE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS NOW OR AFTER THE NEXT
WEEK- I WELL LET TO THE NEXT
SPEED THEN- VERY THREE TO HAVE
HEAR FROM SANDY NATIONAL LAB.
DR BABU. SHALLOW MOLLA. SAID
THEIR NATIONAL LABORATORY HE'S
THE MANAGER OF THE ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES SYSTEMS
DEPARTMENT AND PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR GRID ENERGY STORAGE OUR
PRIOR TO JOINING SNDY IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN HE WAS A
CORPORATE FELLOW AT MONSANTO.
ELECTRONIC MATERIALS COMPANY
WHERE HE LED OUR INDIAN PRODUCT
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ENERGY
STORAGE TECHNOLOGY- HIS HAD A
FOUND IN ROLLING TO SHOW US A
START UPS- MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO VACUUM AND-
MICROELECTRONICS IN FLAT PANEL
DISPLAY TECHNOLOGY SHE IS A
FELLOW OF THE IEEE E. V.
INSTITUTE OF- ELECTRICAL AND
ELECTRONICS ENGINEERS. AND THEY
CAN BE OF SCIENCE IS A SAINT
LOUIS AND I COULD GO ON FOR A
LONG TIME- HE IS CHAIR OF THE-
MRS TRUMBULL. COMMITTEE
RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S OF
TECHNOLOGY AND ELECTRONICS
THAT- AND CATCHERS WHO ARE
UNIVERSITY AND A PHD IN PHYSICS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF NORTH
TEXAS HE'S AUTHORED OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY- PAPERS AND
HAS NINE U. S. PAN. SO DR-
CELLO MOLLENKOPF PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO PICK A GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AND VERY HAPPY TO BE
PRESENTING AT THIS MEETING. AS
A COMPUTER TECHNICIAN MY NAME
IS PUBLIC TELE I'M OUT OF THE
STORE PROGRAM MUCH THAT INITIAL
S. SUNDAY WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE R&D- WORK IN-
MAKING STORAGE SAFE RELIABLE
COST EFFECTIVE. AUGUST MANY END
MARKETS INCLUDING THAT
TRANSPORTATION AND STATION IS
STORAGE. I AM VERY HAPPY TO
FOLLOW ON THE TESTIMONY FROM MY
FAMILY YOU KNOW IT'S EASY HAS
BEEN A LEADING UP MEDITATION
FOR RUNNING FOR PUBLISHING
STORAGE IN THE MARKETPLACE- WE
HAVE A LONG TERM COLLABORATION
WITH- THE ULTRA PRODUCTS
MICROGRAM AT THE CC. I THANK-
MIKE- PUTS US IN THIS
ENGAGEMENT ORDER YES- WE ALSO
HAVE A ROBUST- ENGAGEMENT AT
THE STATE UC'S AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL BASIS I DO SUPPORT
THE POLICY MAKING- MIGHT
PRESENTATION- TODAY IS BASED ON
THAT ENGAGEMENT THE POLICY AND
REGULATORY BODIES FROM THE
COUNTRY. I'M SPECIFICALLY ASKED
ABOUT US- THE QUESTIONS- BEFORE
GOING TO THAT I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD TIME FOR A DISCUSSION OF
THE POLICY AND REGULATORY
ASPECTS. FOR SEASONAL STORAGE.
I THINK I'M A GREAT ASSET- SEE
MOSTLY VENUE I THINK ENOUGH
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT CIVIL
STORAGE WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING. AND THE POLICYMAKERS
HAVEN'T GIVEN ISSUE-
CONSIDERATION ON WHAT IT MEANS.
R. AS A MENTION BY- THIS
BECAUSE EARLIER- CDS R&B
INVESTED RMB AND ENGINEERING ON
SEASONAL STORIES I THINK YOU
JUST BEGINNING AND IT'S A GOOD
TIME TO START EXPLORING WHAT
THE WHAT THE POLICY CHALLENGES
ARE WHAT CAN UP REGULATE
DIFFERENT WHAT CAN YOU DO HAVE.
TO ENABLE THIS INDUSTRY. SO
COMING TO THAT KEY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE ASKED ME TO
RESPOND TO THE FIRST ONE IS. A
WALK IN THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN DO TO ENSURE
THAT MERGING TECHNOLOGIES CAN
MAKE IT FOR THE FIRST EMAIL.
VALLEY OF DEATH SICKENING. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS SPENT MUCH OF
MY CAREER INDUSTRY BEFORE
COMING TO THE LEFT- THE
GREATEST UPSET OBSTACLE BUT
MOST TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING
LONGER THEY SHOULD START A
SEASONAL STORAGE. WE GET ALL OF
THE VALLEY OF DEATH IS COST.
AND FOR THAT PERFORMANCE THANK
YOU KNOW. WE NEED TO OFFER.
SOME VIABLE ALTERNATIVES TO
REPLACE PREDICTION DEMOLITION.
FOUR ONE LONG DURATION STORAGE
CONCEDES AND I JUST PUT AND ALL
THESE- TO MAKE CDS AND WHAT'S-
AT THE CURRENT LEVELS- THEY'RE
QUITE EXPENSIVE. AND
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS NEEDS TO
BE MET- STATE GOVERNMENTS CAN
HELP BUT LOOK CLOSELY THINKING
ALL OBSERVE COST TO THE BURDEN
OF PUTTING IN YOUR STORAGE
EXPECT A LONGER TERM. AND
SEASON ALSO- COOPER CITY'S TAX
INCENTIVES MAY BE AN
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS WHICH CAN
BE FOR SOME OF THE COSTS ARE
PROVIDED. THAT RESTRICT OUR IN
THAT CASE. AND I THINK I ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE OF THE WHOLE PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT- HOW BUT WHAT ABOUT
THE OVERALL SYSTEM EFFICIENCY
IS WIDE OPEN. I'M TIRED OF THIS
AND THEY NEED TO GO UP MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN WHERE WE
ARE. AND THEN. AREAS OF
OPERATION FUNCTIONALITIES HOW
DO YOU BRING THESE PRODUCTS TO
REALITY ON THAT SCALE. IN THOSE
THINGS THAT A LOOK SACRAMENTO
COMES UP THAT'S BANQUETING
SALAS. I PROGRAM LIKE CZ BRING
IN CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO HAVE-
DEAL WORLDS AND IF YOU SO BUT
WE ALSO OF THE LITTLE ONLY IN
THE PROCESS. IN THIS SENSE OF
IN USING. HAS BEEN BEATING THE
AREA- OTHER STATESYOUR- NOT TO
MY SODA JUST AMOUNTS TO WAS TO.
A SUPPORT LONGER ACTIONS. BUT
MOST OF THESE BUT IT'S AN OF
SKILL. TO BECOMES SEASON AND I
STORAGE IS THAT THE MOST A
LONGER MAYBE HOURS HOURS BUT
NOT NECESSARILY ONE CAN SAY
THESE ARE. R. D. O. E. R. OF
ELECTORS THE I THINK IN THIS IS
A OFFICE. AS BEEN SETTLED TO
SUPPORTING THE MOST BUT THERE
FOR MANY YEARS. AND THIS OFFICE
IS JUST BEGINNING TO SEE LONGER
ACTION STORAGE AND SEASONAL
STORE IN THE- AREA. I TOOK A
LOT OF THE ASPECTS AND ALSO YOU
KNOW- BRINGING THE CLIP THE
BODIES- EDUCATIONAL-
INFORMATION- TO DO SO THAT THEY
CAN MAKE. THAT A POLICY MAKING.
SO ASK FOR UPPER OPEN
GOVERNMENTS SO. YOU KNOW THESE
USUALLY FROM OUR DEAL YOU FALL.
AND THEY DON'T OPPORTUNITIES.
THROUGH THE- I AM AND ALSO FOR
THE GRANDCHILDREN PROGRAM WHICH
WAS ANNOUNCED A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO I WHICH I'LL TALK A LITTLE
BIT OF. AND THE SECOND QUESTION
THE COMMITTEE ASKED ME TO
ADDRESS THIS. WHAT POLICY AND
THE COLLECTIVE BODY IF EXIST
BUT STILL IMAGES STORIES
TELLEMENT UNDEFINED. I WOULD
SAY YOUR BILL IF YOU CAN OTHER
POSSIBLE TO BOOK ABOUT STATE IT
USUALLY MEANS RETAIL MARKET.
AND AS A FELLOW THAT YOU ASSUME
IT'S ENOUGH WHAT THE MARKET THE
FEDERAL ELECTIONS. BUT THEY
TELL US THAT. BUT A CALM THAT
WE LOOK AT THE STATE OUR OTHER
PHONE LEVELS. AND UNIQUE-
LOOKING SPECIFIC. I DO GIVE YOU
A COUPLE EXAMPLES- THERE IS A
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NOT THE
MARKET THAT IS LEAKING THAT'S
THE CONSENSUS OF WHAT A MEETING
INVITE LONGER STORAGE. I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
DEFINITIONAL- INFORMATION ON
BOARD THE STORAGE OF STUDENTS
SO IT NEEDS. AND UP AND
EVALUATING- THESE TECHNOLOGIES-
FOR THE MARKETPLACE WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THE SYSTEMS I AM.
ESTIMATING AND CAN IT DO
INSTANTANEOUS TOWARD THE TAP
THE LAUGHING GLASS THAT YOU
NEED. AND HOW DOES THE SYSTEM
CYCLE FOR- FOR GOOD
APPLICATIONS AND WE'RE TALKING
OF THE DATA MOST OF THE ASSETS
OF TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS SO
BASICALLY OPERATORS- HAVE TO
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE THESE
SYSTEMS CAN CYCLE LIKE PUMPED
HYDRO WE NOW HAVE FIFTY
LETTERS. AND THAT OPERATIONAL
LIFETIME. CAN THESE ASSETS LAST
LONGTIME. SO COMPANY AT THE WE
GET THIS THINKING IT. AND THEN
THE OTHER ASPECT IS APPLICATION
BOTH FOR- MONDAY BIRDS AND SEE
THE START YOU KNOW I'S KIND OF
BUT COMPOUNDED BY FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCES IN TECHNOLOGY SIX.
AND ALSO WHAT OTHER POTENTIAL
APPLICATIONS AND WHAT THE REAL
VALUE. OF OKAY AGAIN THE- A
PRODUCT OF LOCALS ALL OPERATORS
CAN. CAN MAKE SENSE FINANCIALLY.
AND THEN FOR THE MOST WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT LONG. BEFORE
US I THINK ONE OF MY COULD BE
USED IN THE B. BEING AT THAT'S
REALLY ABOUT IT- IS A GOOD
THING CAME ABOUT LEAST ANOTHER
THINKS. BUT POLICY MAKE. ARE
JUST BEGINNING TO SEE OFFENSE.
MAY IS A IS A IS THAT HE ASKED
SPOT FOR THE NEXT. BUT WE
HAVEN'T. TALKED ABOUT ANYTHING
BEYOND TEN HOURS. MOST OF THE
LONG DURATION I THINK YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT- ESPECIALLY THOSE
BENEFITS ON BETTER TECHNOLOGY
THAT THE BATTERIES. I THINK
THAT'LL BE COMING TO THE POINT.
POPOVICH HOW CAN YOU WILL GO
BEYOND- WHAT HOURS BUT A LOT OF
LOT OF IDENTIFICATIONS I THINK
IT THAT THAT PROCESS IS STILL A
ONE. THEN THERE IS THAT POLICY
ASPECTS- THAT THAT THEY CAN
DELAY TELEMUNDO FLOW OF MAKING.
AND THAT MEETS THE- NEEDS TO
HAPPEN QUICKLY. SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE A MARKET PLACE FOR-
SEASONAL STORAGE. THIS IS WHERE
WE HAVE SOME LEVEL OF- POLICY I
THINK OF THE- THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK IS VERY PRESCRIPTIVE
THEN YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
GIVING PREFERENTIAL BATTERIES
OR OTHER TECHNOLOGIES. AND
THEN- AS I MENTIONED EARLIER I
THINK THAT A LOT OF INPUTS
MIGHT BECOME AND JEEP
REPUBLICAN- WANTED SO BADLY I
THINK IT MIGHT BE LOOK AT THE
CURRENT REGULATORY FRAMEWORK I
DON'T NEED THE CHEMICAL NOT IF
YOU'LL I THINK THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE. YEAH AND THEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LEVEL I THINK- MANY
STATES DO NOT HAVE ANY POLICY
BENEFITS FOR THE DENTAL. AND
THE LONG DIRECTIONS BUT SEVEN
DOT. ONLY FOR STATES HAVE. SOME
SUBSTANTIAL LEVEL UP A POLICY
THAT WOULD MEAN IN A STORAGE.
BUT ONLY A FEW LIKE A TWENTY OF
THE DOUBLE ADDRESSING ON
DIRECTION AND SEE THEM ONLY
JUST BEING DROPPED. SO YOU THAT
SENSE I THINK IT OFF- YOU
SHOULD THE ART INCONSISTENCY IN.
CONSISTENT IS IN PARTNERSHIP.
THE TERM AND HOW ARE THESE ARE
GOING TO BE- THAT'S ONE GO ASK
BECAUSE MORE LONGER STORAGE.
BUT NOT LIKELY TO EXPENSIVE-
ADRIAN NOT SUPPOSE SITES COST
SO YOU NEED TO HAVE A GOOD
FRAMEWORK ON HOW TO HOW DO YOU-
SEE THE OWNERSHIP ISSUES. AND
THEN FOR ME TO MARKETS AT THE
THAT IT BASS I WOULD BEEN TO
OUR SMOKE BACK PLEASE TRY
ACTION. OBLIGATIONS SO THEY DID
NOT HAVE THE HASN'T BEEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LONG DURATION
TO COME INTO THE PARTICIPATING
BY. THAT TO CHANGE. THEN THAT
EVEN THE IS ABOUT LEVEL WELL
THAT'S AT ENOUGH- I YOU LOOK AT
IT I THINK- A LONGER AGAINST
ALWAYS THAT BE IN. ABSOLUTE
WITH HAVE- A GOOD FAMILY FOR-
THEY'VE BEEN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US LONGER OF A SEASONAL STORAGE
THE WHOLE ACT YEAH. THAT'S A
AREA I THINK IT. OF ME GETTING
EXT. AND IN PLACES YOU HAVE AT
BEST BUY- THE AIM IS TO ENSURE
RESULT IT WAS THE- POSSIBLE.
AND THAT THEY DO NOT A NOT TO
KEEP OF NATION. I CAN TELL TO
THE DOLLAR. I THINK IT'S A GOOD
ASPECT. AND MAY NOT BE ALL THAT.
SO I THINK KNOW THE POLICY-
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND OTHER THINGS
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE POLICY IS
LOCKED UP I THINK IF YOU WANT
TO BRING A TECHNOLOGIST MARKET-
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHICH ARE NOT
REALLY MATURE I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE AT POLICYMAKERS. WE
HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND OTHER
ASPECT IS. WHAT DRIVES THE
INDUSTRY USE THE STANDARDS OF A
FRIEND AND HAVING GOT
STANDARDIZED PROCESSES FOR A- A
TECHNICAL REQUIREMENTS. AND
STREAMLINED BUT IT DON'T
MATTER. ESPECIALLY AROUND
ENOUGH OF YOU TO DO THE COST OF
INSTALLATION. OPERATIONAL
ISSUES. IT WAS CAN HELP YEAH
THOSE ARE THE I THINK THE
KEEPER- IN AT THIS LEVEL. OTHER
ARTISTS LEVEL ARE HOW DO YOU
GETTHEM. NUMBER STORY ALSO
STORAGE ACCEPT IN THE MARKET.
AND COMING TO THE LOS QUESTION
CAN FELLOW FOR SUCH- FUNDING TO
BE LEVERAGE TO AID IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE I THINK MY
ANSWER TO THAT SO WE CAN I CAN
LOOK AT- FISCAL TWENTY TWO-
PRESIDENTIAL- BUTTON BUTTONS
REQUEST OUR OFFICE OF
ELECTRICITY ADEQUATELY FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR A FAMILY OBVIOUSLY SUCH NOT
AS MANY A SELLOUT DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS BUT- IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
FRAMEWORK- THEN THERE ARE
THINGS YOU KNOW. TRANSMISSIONS
IS DUMB AND- THE CONCLUSION
BILL HAS MADE A MISMATCH FOR
LINDA PEANUT TECHNOLOGIES SO
THERE ARE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE IN THE END UP COMING. TO
A FEDERAL BUDGET. AND THE THEY-
OF BILL. WITH THE I JUST RANCHO-
WHICH IS AGAIN A- BUT TO HOLD
ITS- ON HOW DO YOU DO. AND I
JUST. DOMESTICALLY SO THAT- WE
CAN ALL THE- WITHIN THE- BY.
TWENTY THIRTY. THEN- OVER THE
LAST- COUPLE OF MONTHS- NO
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD THAT YOU
YOU EXCELLENT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF. SOME OF THE
CRITICAL. INCLUDING BETTER- DO
YOU A SIGNIFICANT- HAS COME
THAT. THEY'RE GOING TO BE- IT
SIX EIGHT AT THE END OF THE
ENERGY AT SHARKS- OVER THE NEXT
YEAR. HOBBIES ALL THESE I TO
CONVICT. HELLO BOOKS. SOME OF
THE OUT OF THE TECHNOLOGY- IN
THE MARKET MISS- BOTH INSIDE SO
THAT WITHIN THERE YES. I'M NOT
THOSE- AND TRY TO. YOU SHOULD
USE THE FIRST TWO SHE AND I OUR
CENTERED ON- ONE DIRECTION
STORAGE AND HYDROGEN STROKE SO
LONG GREAT THE SHUT I THINK
ENOUGH HAS AMBITIOUS TALK AT TO
GET THE OVERALL CUTS SYSTEM
COSTS BY NINETY PERCENT. OF
ADULTS TEMPLES ALSO DIRECTION
WITHIN A TICKET. AND THE- YEAH
I THINK YOU'RE NOT LOOKING AT
ADVANCING BECAUSE GETTING THE
GOAL BUT FUNDING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT NATIONAL LABS BUT
STILL DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
DEPLOYMENTS AND- AND GETTING
BEAT THAT THE MYSTIC MEDICATION
INDUSTRY TO BRING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. THEN THE HEAD
AGAIN HAVE CHART- IS- A VERY
AMBITIOUS- TO CUT THE COST OF
ITEMS- BY EIGHTY PERCENT- TO
BRING HADN'T BILL ONE DOLLAR
COLLAPSE I MEAN AT THAT POINT
BUT ONE DOLLAR A KILOGRAM IT'S
BEEN A VERY COMPLICATED WITH
NATURAL GAS. OR ANY OF THE
OTHER- COME DISTRICTS- SO I
THINK IMMA LOOKING AT THE HE'S
BEEN. AT INITIATE MANY CAN SEE-
THAT A- SIGNIFICANT FOCUS ON
THINGS. I RECOMMENDATIONS
STORAGE- IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION. AND I THINK
THERE ARE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO MOVE THINGS FORWARD VERY
QUICKLY. WITH THAT I WILL STOP.
TAKING PATIENTS. THANK YOU I'M
THANK YOU SO IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT THE ISO EXCUSE ME THAT THE
ARM. ENERGY COMMISSION FUNDS
RESEARCH BUT NOT. NOT THE KIND
OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS THAT
ARE NATIVE FOR SCALE UP TO WHAT
EXTENT DO YOU THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN BE PREPARED TO
ARM. JOINTLY WORK WITH
COMPANIES WHERE THEY'RE
INVESTING THEIR MONEY AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS CALLED
BUYING DOWN THE COST OF
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE PILOT
PLANTS AND FRANKLY IN
CALIFORNIA FROM WHAT I'VE JUST
HEARD. OKAY NEED TO PRODUCE
THIS IN LIKE FOR. FIFTY
DEVELOPMENT TAKES ANOTHER
COUPLE OF YEARS AND IT'S
PROBABLY TAKES LONGER EIGHT WE
HAVE LIKE FIVE YEARS TO DEPLOY
IT- AT ANY RATE DO YOU SEE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GETTING
INVOLVED. IN THESE LARGE SCALE
INVESTMENTS. I THINK THAT WITH
THE IDEALIZATION THAT THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT CDS TOGETHER
COUNTRY. AND AND- AND- BASED ON
THE AND THE BABY NEW
INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS ARE
BEING STRUCTURE. THAT IS A MUCH
GREATER LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT
WITH INDUSTRY. THAT SAID I
THINK IN ALL THESE A SLOWER
PROCESS THIS. BUT THE POLICY
AND- AND THE DIRECTION SEEMS TO
BE- HOW DO WE ACTUALLY MOVE
THINGS FORWARD BUT IT QUICKLY-
WITH AND GET YOU THAT THIS
INDUSTRY- ANOTHER THING I'LL
BRING UP. AND YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF THIS BUT- IN
THE- WE MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY.
PASSED THROUGH THE SENATE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THREE AND
A HALF TRILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE PLANNING
TO DO MOST OF THE MONEY THAT
WOULD BUILD ADDITIONAL
RENEWABLE RESOURCES. UP FOR
LARGE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY-
THEY DON'T HAVE THE KIND OF.
DEPLOYMENT THAT WE DO ALREADY
IN CALIFORNIA. SO FOR THEM
STORAGE MAY NOT BE IS IMPORTANT
BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
STORAGE IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT. DO WE KNOW IF THERE
ARE THOUGHT TO CONGRESS ABOUT
NOT ONLY- PAYING FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE RENEWABLE
RESOURCES BUT ALSO STORAGE JUST
BUYING STORAGE AS THEY WOULD
BUY- RENEWABLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T KNOW BUT BUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE IN THE OFFICE OF
BOOKING OF THE TECHNOLOGIES AND
THE THAT IS A IT'S A IT'S A BIG
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FOCUS ON
NON. DEMONSTRATIONS OF ENERGY
STORAGE- IN THE IN THE BUDGET
IS. I THINK THEY COULD BE GOOD
OPTIONS BUT ALL THE STATE'S
BUDGET SCRIPT UNNECESSARILY-
CALIFORNIA NEW YORK. ALL RIGHT
VERY GOOD- SO- MISTER BRADLEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON ON HOW YOU
SEE- YOU'RE YOU'RE INVESTING
NOW IN A LOT OF R. AND D. HOW
YOU SEE DEPLOYMENT OF SOME OF
THESE. NEW TECHNOLOGIES WE
HEARD THREE DIFFERENT ONE FROM
DOCTOR KURTZ WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
THE IRON- AIR BATTERY WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT HYDROGEN. WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION BE INVOLVED
IN- SAY TRYING TO HELP. AT
LEAST COME UP WITH POLICY FOR
HOW WE DEVELOP- THE PILOT
PLANTS AND A SHOW THE
FEASIBILITY OF THE SOME STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES. IN LARGE SCALE.
IT CERTAINLY I BELIEVE THAT'S A
KEY ELEMENT FOR WHAT WE'RE
DOING I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
VERY IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
YOU'VE MENTIONED THIS THIS
LARGE STORAGE NEEDS AND SPACE
SEASONAL COURSES OR OTHER
SHORTER DURATION STORAGE BUT
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
IN A GROWING BE FORCED
COMPANIES JUST TO GET THE
INVESTMENT COMMUNITIES
INTERESTED ENOUGH TO SEE THE
VALUE. THERE IS PROBABLY A
THIRD OF THE STATE'S IN UNITED
STATES AND HAVE SIMILAR GOALS
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ZERO CARBON-
INFRASTRUCTURE BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW CALIFORNIA
HAS IT SO ONE OF THE THINGS
IT'S TO PERFORMANCE AND THE
VALUE SO IT IS JUST SOMETHING
THE STATE'S GOING TO PAY FOR
AND YOU HAVE TO GO DEMONSTRATE
VERY ONE THING BUT WHAT WE
TRYING DEMONSTRATED FACT THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
PAY FOR ITSELF AND HAVE A
COMMERCIAL OPPORTUNITY. I WOULD
USE YOUR FOR EXAMPLE YOU
MENTIONED THE FOR MANAGING
THEIR SEVERAL COPIES WERE DOING
THAT LOOKING AT A HUNDRED HOURS
OF STORAGE BUT ONE OF THE
CONCEPT IS FOR THOSE TYPES OF
HUNDRED OUR STORAGE SYSTEMS IS
THEY WOULD OPERATE EVERY DAY
CAN BE SELLING ENERGY IN THE
MARKET PLACE TO BE I CHAU TELL
UTILITIES TENNESSEE CH EVERY
DAY IN ADDITION TO HAVING. A
FEW DAYS OR A WEEK A CONTINUAL
STORAGE WITH THEM SO THEY'RE
MAKING MONEY ON THEIR PAY
YOUNGER OVER HERE THEIR PAIN OR
EXPENSES ON A DAILY BASIS BUT
THEN THEY ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BRINGING ONE THIS ONE IS
REALLY NEEDED THESE LONGER
DURATIONS SO I DO THINK ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WERE FACING AND
IS TO CONVINCE THE INVESTMENT
COMMITTED BECAUSE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE WE RUN INTO
WHEN YOU SAY WE WANT TO SCALE
UP THE SAME VIDEO PROJECT OF A
HUNDRED KILOWATTS WE WANT TO GO
TO ONE MEGAWATT- FIVE
MEGAWATTS. FOR THAT COMPANY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT THEY NEED IN
MOST CASES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE THE UTILITY OR THE
CUSTOMER WOULD LIKE TO DO A
POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENT A LONG
TERM AGREEMENT SIX TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS AND SO THEY HAVE
TO BE AN INVESTMENT A
CAPABILITY THAT WILL DO THAT
AND SO THE WORK THAT WE DO IS
TRYING TO PROVE TO THAT
COMMUNITY THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS REAL. THE COMPANY IS REAL
THE TO TECHNOLOGY WORK AND IT'S
TO. UP THANK YOU YOUR CALL.
WHEN YOU AT THE PARK.
CALIFORNIA THE- ARE COUNTRY.
THERE IS A RAY. GROW OF MANAGED.
BUT IT'S TO END UP NEEDING CUT
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY NEEDS ON.
HOW THOSE PROBLEMS ACROSS BASIS.
CAN ACTUALLY OF PAY THEM SO
WITH THE- THEY PROVIDING. TO
THE UTILITY TOOK AGREE. AND TO
THE STATE- THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
THAT I SEE. ARE FOR THIS
SEASONAL. STORAGE IF WE GO TO.
A WHAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY- DR
BURGER. THERE IS GOING TO BE A
YEAR OUT THERE. WHERE WE'RE
GONNA NEED A HUNDRED HOURS OF
STORAGE OR SOMETHING LIKE A
HUNDRED HOURS OF- TO REDUCE
POWER ON THE ORDER OF TWENTY
GIGA WATCH FOR HUNDRED HOURS.
MAYBE ONCE EVERY THIRTY YEARS
BUT YOU CAN'T AFFORD. NOT TO
HAVE THAT HUNDRED HOURS IN
RESERVE. BUT ORDINARILY YOU'RE
ONLY GONNA NEED. MAYBE FIVE
HOURS OR TEN HOURS AT MOST
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO NEED A
HUNDRED UP ONCE EVERY TEN YEARS
I THINK HE SAID SOMETHING LIKE
IT'S FIFTY HOURS AND YOU KNOW
THEY SELL ONE CASE WERE WITH A
HUNDRED DOWN FOR THIRTY YEARS
WORTH OF DATA. SO YOU'VE GOT
STORAGE THAT IS GOD SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER A HUNDRED HOURS WORTH
OF STORAGE BUT ON A DAILY BASIS
YOU'RE ONLY USING ABOUT FIVE
HOURS. THE ECONOMICS OF THIS
ARE NOT GOOD- WE HEARD FROM DR
KIRCH TALKING ABOUT THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE
WHICH YOU HAVE FOR EMERGENCIES.
IT'S NOT GOING TO EVER PAY FOR
ITSELF A HUNDRED HOURS WORTH OF
STORAGE WHEN YOU'RE USING FIVE
OR IF MOST CHEN. ON A DAILY
BASIS IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO
PAY FOR ITSELF SO I THINK. WELL
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE PAID FOR BY
RATE PAYERS OR SOME OTHER
INVESTMENT BUT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE I THINK COMMERCIALLY
SOMETHING. WELL IN THE END
REPAIRS TO PAY FOR ALL THE
ELECTRICITY THE POINT IS THAT
THIS IS A HUGE AMOUNT OF
STORAGE THAT YOU'RE PAYING FOR
AND VERY SELDOM GET TO USE. SO
YOU KNOW THE COSTS ARE HIGH.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THAT DAILY-
REVENUE. AND IT MEANS THE COST
OF ELECTRICITY IS GOING TO BE
QUITE HIGH. THAT IS THE
QUESTION THAT I WILL POINT OUT
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT BUT
BOTH DR COURAGE AND ARE WITH
BIGGER FROM FOR FOUR MINUTES
YOU HAVE THE TWO DIFFERENT
GRANTS WE HAVE WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE QUESTION.
OF LONG DURATION SEASONAL
STORAGE AND WHAT THE ROLE IS IN
CALIFORNIA NOW IF IT'S JUST BE
ONE HUNDRED. SO IT IS A TOUGH
QUESTION. IT IS AN AREA WHERE
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IN OTHER WORDS OF MAYBE
JUST EMERGING STORAGE BY ITSELF
IS NOT THE ONLY SOLUTION. WE
TALKED ABOUT LOOK VEHICLES AND-
THE DOCTOR CHRIS MENTIONED YOU
KNOW HOW TO TURN THE TRUCKS
BEING ABLE TO BE A GREAT ASSET.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST EFFORTS
PERCENT LOOK AT VEHICLES IN THE
COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
LARGE ROADS WE CAN VERY VOCAL
HAVE. THEM AS AN ASSET IT FOR
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS SO I
THINK IT DEMAND RESPONSE IS A
BIG EFFORT IN CALIFORNIA TROOPS
AND LOAD MANAGEMENT SO I THINK.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SOLUTION
AND I AGREE WITH YOU ONE PERSON
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE FACE
AND WON THE CHALLENGES WE WANT
TO FIGURE OUT IS HOW DO WE
ADDRESS JUST. FOR YOUR CORRECT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT THE TOP ONE
TO SAY OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
POWER YOU KNOW- BUT TWICE A
YEAR YOU CAN EXPECT TO LOSE
EVERYTHING I HAVE TALKED ON THE
WORK WE HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION
FOR EVERYTHING. AND SO I THINK
WE JUST NEED TO LOOK AT IT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE HOPING
TO DO IS TO DO THAT BALANCED
APPROACH AND TO LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS TO
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES. ONE OF
THE INTERESTING THINGS I CAN
SHARE YOU KNOW WITH THE GRANTS
THAT WE ARE HAVING AT THE END
OF. ESTIMATED COST THAT THE
GREAT TO USE REQUESTED MEETING
IS SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER THAN IF
YOU MY INTEREST IN THE FORTY
WILL MAKE COMPETE AND FUTURE
AND HAVE A SPREADER SOLUTION IN
THIS PLACE STATE COULD BE
PAYING SUBSTANTIALLY LESS. THAN
DEMOCRATIC TODAY SO YOU KNOW
THE ONE THING THAT LITHIUM ION
DOES FOR THE MARKET PLACE I'VE
BEEN IN AS LONG AS I HAVE. IS A
SENSE OF PRICE POINT IN THE
PERFORMANCE POINT THAT
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE ARE-
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET CHOI DOES GIVE US THAT
BUT I DO THINK YOU YOU HAVE
DEFINITELY HIT. AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S A CLEAR NEED. I DON'T
THINK IT'S TOMORROW BUT YOU'RE
CORRECT TWENTY THIRTY TWENTY
FORTY OF MADE UP WE THINK WE
CAN MAYBE CAN'T. WAIT TO TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. BUT I DO THEY- WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE UP. AND I
DO. SOME OF THE- EMERGING. THAT
WE HAVE HAVE A LOT. I THINK
STATE TIGER THE MORE POPULAR.
TECHNOLOGY IN THE- MOST OF
PROGRAM TECHNOLOGY IN THE WORLD.
IN IT HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN THE
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER TO. DOES
REAL QUESTIONS NO TO BE YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE LIVE WITH ON A
COMPOUND HE KAMALA BASIS AS WE
GROW DISTRICT. AND HELD A WEEK
JUST TO FIVE. THE COST THAT
WE'RE PAYING IN THE SERVICE FOR
GETTING AND SO THAT'S AN AREA
THAT WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
IN OUR RESEARCH IS JUST TRYING
TO MAKE THAT TRADE OFF. BETWEEN
WHAT IS THE PERFORMANCE WE NEED
AND WHERE ARE WE WILLING TO PAY
FOR IT AND HOW CAN WE DO THAT
IN A MANNER WHERE WE INTEGRATE
DRINKS. AND PAY LESS MAYBE A
HALF OR A THIRD OF WHAT IT
MIGHT BE IF WE DIDN'T INTEGRATE
THOSE DIFFERENT CONNECTIONS
TOGETHER YES. I'M NUMBER CLERK.
I'M GONNA MAKE MY- AND I I'D
LOVE TO HEAR. IS THAT WAS-
TALKING ABOUT PUMPED HYDRO. IN
THE WHOLE COUNTRY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEGAWATT HOURS OF
STORAGE. THAT'S FROM A
WIKIPEDIA ARTICLE IT'S PROBABLY
RIGHT TO WITHIN A FACTOR OF TWO
OR SO. NOT SURE HOW MUCH THE
REASON CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S
PROBABLY ON THE ORDER
250-005-0000 MEGAWATT HOURS. IT
THAT'S A FAIR AMOUNT AND IT'S
MORE THAN BATTERIES OR ANYTHING
ELSE BUT- AGAIN FOR SEASONAL
STORAGE WE'RE GOING TO NEED
BILLIONS. A MEGAWATT HOURS I
DON'T HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER BUT
JUST TALKING TO THE EXPERTS
HERE TODAY. YOU KNOW WITH. THIS
SORT OF SMALL- HOW CAN I SAY
JUST BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATIONS IT COMES TO
MILLIONS. IF WE HAVE TWENTY
FIVE OR FIFTY THOUSAND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OF THAT AND IT TO
SCALE UP. TO GO FROM TO TWENTY
FIVE OR FIFTY THOUSAND TWO
MILLION IS JUST HUGE AND IT
TAKES A LONG TIME AT LEAST TEN
YEARS TO. BUILD ONE OF THESE
PROJECTS PROBABLY ANOTHER TEN
YEARS TO GET IT PERMITTED. SO
IT'S A TOUGH PROBLEM I THINK
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE AND- HOW
CAN WE DEPLOY THIS QUICKLY
ENOUGH TO MATTER HOW CAN WE
MAKE SURE AS DR RAM. FROM- A
LARGE BERKELEY SAID IT IT TAKES
A LONG TIME TO DEVELOP THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND LONGER STILL
TO DEPLOY THEM SO WE ARE IN AN
EMERGENCY HERE I THINK THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE IF THIS WHOLE
HEARING. OKAY WHO WHAT WHAT IS
GOING ON OR SAYING ONE THING GO
AHEAD I JUST CALLED ONE HUNDRED
THINGS ARE GONNA GET WE DO HAVE
A TEN YEAR HISTORY. OF WORKING
ON ALL TECHNOLOGIES IN RECENTLY
WE WERE GOING THROUGH JUST A
TERM WHO COULD HELP US WITH
SOME OF THE HEAT RANGE AND WE
HAVE BABY. THIRTY TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE DIFFERENT THAT WE WORK
WITH AND IT'S PROBABLY EIGHT TO
TEN OF THEM HAVE GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY'RE READY FOR
RAPID SCALE UP AND SO THERE AND
THERE'S ANOTHER TWO OR THREE TO
BEAT. JEFF WAITED TILL LATER SO
WE DO HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING THIS CHALLENGE AND WE
DO HAVE OPTIONS AND AGAIN
EVERYBODY YOU RECALL TODAY.
MOST OF WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
GRANT SOMEWHERE IN THEIR
HISTORY. AND SO WE'RE FORTUNATE
TO DO THAT BUT I DO THINK YOU
KNOW AS WE GO FORWARD YOU KNOW
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
LEVERAGE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED AND
TAKE SOME RISKS WITH SOME OF
THE COMPANIES THAT WE THINK ARE
READY. BECAUSE I WOULD AGREE WE
CANNOT GET THIS ON A HUNDRED
KILOWATTS OF THE TIMER ONE
MEGAWATT WEEK WE DO TEND TO
MAKE A WATCHING WE NEED. TO
ENSURE WE GET TOGETHER TODAY
HERE KEEP SENATE BABY THOUSAND
MEGAWATT HOURS WE NEED. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS AND WE JUST GOT
TO FIND THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT
SO THAT WE CAN MEET OUR NEEDS
AND- IN AN ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT
AND WE DON'T HAVE THIS BIG.
COST THAT WE'RE PUTTING OUT
THERE PERCENT BEEN RESTORED
ONCE IN THE SUMMER OVER THREE
MONTHS YOU MAY USE IT FOR TEN
DAYS IN THE WINTER WE DON'T USE
IT THE NEXT YEAR. BUT WE HAVE
TO FIND A WAY TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF WHAT CHOICES THAT WE HAVE.
AND THAT'S A PROMISING START OR
DO YOU THINK I MEAN I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED THIS A LONG TIME I SEE
MORE PROMISED MORE OPPORTUNITY
AND MORE INVESTMENT. IN STORAGE
NOW OPEN AND PROBABLY THE
PREVIOUS TWENTY FIVE YEARS THAT
I WAS IN THE INDUSTRY. SO I
JUST THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
HOPE BUT I DO THINK YOU'RE
ASKING SOME TOUGH QUESTIONS-
WE'RE GOING UP TO THINK ABOUT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO INTEGRATE
YOUR AND YOUR POLICY REPORT AT
THE COMMISSION. THIS MAY BE A
QUESTION DETECTING SHOULD LOOK
AT AND ONE OF OUR FUTURE GREAT
POST REPORTS JUST HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS LONG TERM STORAGE
NEEDS. AND HOW DO WE BEGIN TO
PLAN FOR THAT BECAUSE I THINK
YOU KNOW IT ACTUALLY I WATCHED
WHAT I THINK. THREE YEARS AGO
WHEN WE STARTED THIS LONG STORY
SEPARATE I HAVE A UNIVERSITY OF
CUT I MEAN A GROUP OF STUDENTS
FROM STANFORD. COOKING. TO ME
LOOKING FOR A PROJECT I SO. I
WILL GIVE YOU SIMPLE PROJECT. I
WILL GIVE IT. COME TO CALL. BUT
I DON'T KNOW WORKABLE. VERSION
I WANT YOU TO CALL. IN EACH OF
ASKHAM. WHY YOU'RE- IN A TECHNO.
THAT NO. SHOULD WE NEED. AND
COURSE. EVERYBODY THEY WERE.
FOURTH BUT I'M JUST. WAS YOU.
AGO THREE TO FOUR. YEARS AGO.
LOW STORE. WAS NOT CONSIDER.
URGENT NEED. AND I THINK. TODAY
WE SEE OKAY. PART OF THE MIX.
THE HAVE TO BE PART OF A I
WOULD NOT GO. BILL MAKE. FUTURE.
THAT'S GREAT NOW WHO WILL SERVE.
TO SPEAK. SAYS SINCE I CAN SEE
IT RECOGNIZE YOU JUST SHOUT OUT.
AND- BE GLAD THAT GOT. REAL
APPRECIATE THAT A AFTER AT THE
AND THIS KIND AGAIN FORMAT- I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY A COUPLE-
TO AN ADDER TO- WOOD MISTER
GRAY THEY WERE SAYING. AS THE
FIRST ONE I'M GONNA. IT IN THE
NOW THAT WE DID. WITH THAT
COUGH PUBLIC UTILITIES. DATA WE
HAVE FOUND THAT THE ONE OUR
REMOVE ENERGY SHORTFALL. HAPPEN
ONE EVERY TEN YEARS NOT ONCE A
THIRTY. THE THESE HAPPEN OF
WITHIN THE RELIABILITY PLANNING
STANDARDS UP TO DATE AND THE
FIFTY OUR SHORTFALLS ACTUALLY
HAPPEN EVERY OTHER YEAR. THESE
ARE AT THEIR KNEES ARE ACTUALLY
VERY COMMON IT AND SO. WHAT I
WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT IN IN IN
THIS IS THE POINT THAT BUILT ON
WHAT BANISTER GREAT GREAT IT
WAS JUST SAYING IS THAT. WE
EXPECT THESE LONGER DURATION OR
MULTI DAY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES
TO BE PARTICIPATING IN THAT
CASE- MARKETS AND YOU KNOW
OTHER ENERGY MARKETS EVERY
SINGLE DAY EARNING REVENUES
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND ON TOP OF
THAT THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
POWER US THROUGH THESE THESE-
LOW RENEWABLE ENERGY EVENTS THE
SHORTFALLS. AND SO I WOULD I
JUST WOULD- WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO KIND OF PAY TO SIT
AROUND AND DO NOTHING FOR THE
ONCE EVERY THIRTY YEARS. THESE
ARE THINGS THAT WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE WILL BE ECONOMIC. WITH
THE RIGHT SUPPORT AND KIND OF
THE RIGHT RAMP UP OVER TIME I
SAY WE CAN ENTER THE MARKET AND
REALLY PARTICIPATE ON A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. YUP. BUT ON THE
DAY TO DAY BASIS. YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE USED. A HOURS TO
STORE YOU'RE GOING TO BE. SAY
FIVE. AND YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
MONEY. IN THIS DAILY WORK JUST
WITH FIVE. BUT WE NEED A
HUNDRED. AND SO THAT'S TWENTY
TIMES THE BEING IT LEAST
INVESTMENT IN HARDWARE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IT COUNTS FOR
OVERALL BUT THE POINT IS.
NOBODY'S GOING TO BE OUT THERE
AND THINKING OH I'M GONNA SELL
A HUNDRED HOURS EVERY TEN YEARS
AND SO WELL BUILT TO THAT
CAPACITY NOW. DAILY BASIS FIVE
HOURS THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GONNA
BELTED- YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
A VENTURE CAPITAL GUY I DON'T
THINK. WHO SAYS OH WELL- YOU
KNOW. THE PRICE OF ELECTRICITY
WILL BE SO HIGH IN THAT YEAR.
THAT WILL MAKE ALL OUR MONEY
BACK THAT'S PROBABLY YOU KNOW
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A MEGAWATT
HOUR SUNSET YOU'RE MORE. BUT
YOU HAVE TO DO TO GET YOUR
INVESTMENT BACK. ON HUNDRED
HOURS. AND YOU CAN GET THE FIVE
OUR INVESTMENT IN OUR EVERYDAY.
SAM OKAY- OTHER COMMENTS DR
KURTZ. WHERE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT IF SO SPEAK
UP OR FOREVER HOLD YOUR PEACE.
ANYONE ELSE ALL RIGHT THEN I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE ENDED UP THE
PANEL PORTION UMBRELLA PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I THE SPEAKERS HERE
BEEN FANTASTIC AND I WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF- PER
PARTICULARLY MARIE CANAL HAS A
SCIENCE FELLOW IN HIS UP WITH
ME HERE ON THE DAIS. OF PLEASE
HAVE CAMERA FOCUS IN ON MARIE
CANAL A SCIENCE FELLOW SHE'S
JUST DONE AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB
I'VE NEVER HAD A BETTER- SET OF
NOTES TO WORK FROM TO GIVE MY
INITIAL SPEECH. AND AS SHE JUST
DID A FANTASTIC JOB PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER SO THANK YOU. IF
WE HAD AN AUDIENCE HERE AS
OPPOSED TO EVERYONE REMOTE WE
HAVE SOME APPLAUSE. OKAY SO
THERE IS NO ONE IN PHYSICALLY
IN THE AUDIENCE SO WE WILL GO
TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
AT THE REMOTE STATION JUST
SPEAK UP IF YOU'RE THERE AND-
WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU SO.
THEN YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
SPEAK SO IF THERE'S SOMEONE AT
THE REMOTE STATION- PLEASE
SPEAK UP NOW. ARE YOU REFERRING
TO PEOPLE ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
PHONE MODERATOR PLEASE- ARE
ASKING THOSE WHO ARE WAITING
TO- REQUEST TO SPEAK. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE
CONFERENCE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. AND I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
TURN THE CALL OVER TO LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALAN APPS WITH THE BAY
AREA. AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS IMPORTANT AND INFORMATIVE
HEARING I WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO BRING THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO LOCAL AGENCY
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE HELPFUL.
IN ADDRESSING STORAGE SUCH AS
THE BAY AREA H. U. M. D.'S
CLIMATE TECH FINANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH BRIDGES THE FINANCIAL GAP
FOR CLEANTECH ENTREPRENEURS.
WITH LOAN GUARANTEES. IT
OFFSETS RISK FOR ARE PARTNERING
LENDERS AND INCREASES ACCESS TO
CAPITAL FOR ENTREPRENEURS AND
THE PROJECTS. OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS THE BAY AREA HMD HAS
CONDUCTED OUTREACH TO OVER ONE
THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS. POSTED
TECHNOLOGY SHOWCASES VETTED
POTENTIAL TECHNOLOGIES FOR
FUNDING AND WORK WITH
ENTREPRENEURS COULD TRANSITION
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS IN THE
MARKET GROWTH. WE'VE BEGUN
PARTNERING PROJECT WITH LENDERS
MOST RECENTLY INCLUDING
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY. AND
SOLAR BATTERY MICRO GRIDS FOR
FACILITIES AROUND THE BAY AREA.
LOCAL PROGRAMS LIKE THE CLIMATE
TECH FINANCE PROGRAM CAN HELP
ACCELERATE CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGY. INCLUDING STORAGE
BY CAN I. THE NONTRADITIONAL
AGENT THE EXPERTS AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS IN MIND THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ASSIST
AGENCIES LIKE THE BAY AREA HMD
IN HELPING MORE OF THESE
PROJECTS TO PARESH PERMISSION.
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
AFTER THE HEARING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I AND- THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ARE DEFINITELY
INTERESTED. IF YOU CAN. EMAIL
MAYOR OR MY STAFF AND- AND SEND
US- JUST SOME INFORMATION ON
YOUR PROJECTS ARE WILL BE VERY
INTERESTED TO HEAR ABOUT IT
THANK YOU. OCT GO AHEAD- THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY WELL- YOU
KNOW I'VE LEARNED A LOT TODAY-
AND I THINK THIS SERGEANTS WHO
ARE HERE. ARM I NOTICED THEM
LISTENING WITH RAPT ATTENTION.
AND I THINK THEY LEARNED
SOMETHING TOO AND- WE COURSE
HAVE QUITE A FEW FEW VIEWERS
ONLINE. WHAT I'VE LEARNED-
TALKING TO IS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED A LOT MORE STORAGE BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THAT BY TWENTY
FIFTY WE NEED A NUMBER WHICH IS
MILLIONS COMPARED TO WHAT WE
HAD MILLIONS OF MEGAWATT HOURS
COMPARED TO WHAT WE HAVE NOW
WHICH IS TENS OF THOUSANDS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SCALING UP
BY A FACTOR OF A HUNDRED
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY FORTY
FIVE WHEN WE WANT TO HAVE. A
RENEWABLE GRID. LET ME SAY
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YEAH
AND ROUGH NUMBERS A HUNDRED.
TIMES AS MUCH STORAGE MOST OF
THE STORAGE NOW BEING- A HYDRO
BUT- BATTERIES BECOMING A
BIGGER AND BIGGER PART OF THAT
THE BATTERY IS NOT ABLE TO WORK
ON A SEASONAL BASIS. LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES OTHER TYPES OF
BATTERIES YES AND WE HEARD
ABOUT ONE OF THEM THE IRON AIR
BATTERIES TODAY- SO. THERE'S
SOME THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH
GOING ON. SOME OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES SOUND LIKE THEY'RE
READY TO GET OUT THERE AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED THEM IN
TWENTY THIRTY. AND SELL IT. YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS TO MAKE THAT CRISIS WE
HAVE A CRISIS NOW IN DEPLOYING
ENOUGH STORAGE SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY MEET OUR GOALS IN TWENTY
THIRTY AND IN THE TWENTY FORTY
FIVE FOR DECARBONIZING THE GRID
AND EVENTUALLY DECARBONISING
OUR SOCIETY. SO THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE. I THINK THAT
CAME INTO CLEARER TODAY AND- I
THINK WE DID SOME GOOD WORK I
WANT TO THANK AGAIN ALL THE
SPEAKERS IN MY STAFF PARTICULAR
MARIE CANAL. AND I CALL THIS
HEARING TO AN END.